bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur Public Sénat et elle a une cet
après-midi ce rapport du Sénat qui
s'alarme sur l'état des finances locales
plusieurs villes de moins de 50 000
habitants pourrait être un solvable en
2017 commune département et région vont
devoir prendre des mesures correctives
pour ne pas sombrer dans l'endettement
les sénateurs on appelle donc au
gouvernement comme nous l'explique l'UMP
Charles Guénet au micro de Jonathan
Tissier
on lui demande de reconsidérer sa copie
et de bloquer bon des amendements sont
faits dans ce sens pour réduire parce
qu'il n'est pas question de refuser je
veux dire cette contribution mais les
questions de bien regarder l'impact
qu'elle peut avoir car le remède risque
d'être
chaud je veux dire que le mal
sur la baisse des dotations
collectivités territoriales à 19h avec
notre invité le sénateur UMP philippe
Dallier premier bureau du Sénat depuis
l'élection de Gérard Larcher ce matin le
président du Sénat qui a annoncé la
création d'un groupe de travail sur la
gouvernance du Sénat pour je cite
renforcer l'exemplarité et la
transparence un groupe de réflexion sur
les méthodes de travail du Sénat
également voir le jour il devra
réfléchir à la manière de mieux
solenniser le vote des sénateurs et
comment renforcer leur présence enfin le
bureau du Sénat validé ce matin la mise
en place d'une délégation aux
entreprises ne vous en parlions la
semaine dernière la commission des lois
a finalement adopté ce matin le rapport
sur la lutte contre les discriminations
rédigées par les sénateurs Esther
Benbassa et Jean-René lecer il avait
suscité deux heures et demie de débats
dont les sujets abordés ont fait
polémique au sein de la commission parmi
les thèmes sensibles notamment en
l'enseignement du fait religieux à
l'école mais pas seulement en écoute à
ce propos la sénatrice Europe Écologie
Les Verts interrogé par Pauline dames
aujourd'hui il faut mesurer les
discriminations pour pouvoir et lutter
contre et voir pourquoi la
discrimination va de l'école jusqu'à la
vie professionnelle et le logement etc
l'important c'est de savoir de savoir et
de mesurer et aujourd'hui on ne mesure
pas donc on peut faire semblant de ne
pas savoir
de ton fort cet après-midi au Sénat le
bel effet SS projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale dont
l'examen se poursuit cet après-midi mais
aussi les auditions dessinateurs sur les
différents crédits contenus dans le
projet de loi de finances et cet
après-midi à l'Est sénateurs et bien
auditionne Stéphane Le Foll ministre de
l'Agriculture une audition qui s'inscrit
dans un contexte troublé pour les
agriculteurs effectivement puisque la
semaine dernière encore et bien les
agriculteurs manifestaient pour montrer
leur exaspération ils se sentent
accablés par les nouvelles
réglementations par exemple une nouvelle
réglementation sur le nitrate ils
estiment qu'on ne consomme pas assez
français il y a eu d'ailleurs des
actions devant le ministère de
l'Économie à Bercy ils doivent faire
face enfin aux conséquences de l'embargo
russe et pourtant pourtant le
gouvernement a tenté de donner quelques
gages et cela depuis le mois de
septembre avec notamment et bien
l'enterrement de l'écotaxe et encore le
fin octobre le versement anticipé de 3,4
milliards d'euros prévus par la Pâque et
la politique agricole commune mais voilà
les agriculteurs réclament des mesures
plus durables alors qu'y a-t-il à
attendre du budget 2015 pour les
agriculteurs bah pour les agriculteurs
malheureusement plutôt des mauvaises
nouvelles puisque les budgets étaient en
baisse d'environ 4 % le ministère et les
organismes associés comme les Chambres
d'agriculture ou encore l'Office
National des Forêts bien vont devoir se
serrer la ceinture il y a quand même
quelques côtés positifs puisque le
budget de l'enseignement supérieur de la
recherche tout ce qui est consacré aux
jeunes et enfin toutes les aides pour
l'agroécologie bien tout ça ce sont des
budgets en hausse enfin rappelons que le
gouvernement estime que la baisse des
crédits va être compensée par les
allègements des charges sociales qui
sont prévues dans le cadre du pacte de
responsabilité ça fait tout de même 730
millions d'euros rappelons que les
professionnels ne cessent de réclamer
une baisse du coût de travail pour que
l'agriculture française soit plus
compétitive notamment face à nos voisins
allemands ou encore espagnol ils auront
au moins cette satisfaction merci
beaucoup Tam donc audition de Stéphane
Le folla suivre dans un instant mais en
attendant je vous propose de prendre la
direction de l'hémicycle ou les
sénateurs ont repris cet après-midi
l'examen du projet de budget de la
Sécurité sociale la séance est présidée
par la sénatrice UMP Isabelle de Bron on
se retrouve à tout à l'heure 19h
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
la suite de la discussion du projet de
loi adopté par l'Assemblée nationale de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2015 nous sommes parvenus à la réponse
du gouvernement
la parole est à Madame le Ministre c'est
à vous je vous laisse la parole si vous
le souhaitez
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur général
madame la rapporteur pour la branche
famille
mesdames les sénatrices c'est messieurs
les sénateurs je veux tout d'abord vous
remercier au nom de la ministre Marisol
Touraine pour vos interventions les
discussions que vous aurez sur le texte
permettront certainement d'approfondir
les questions que vous avez soulevées et
les propositions que vous avez formulées
je venais en moins aujourd'hui vous
donner un certain nombre de réponses au
nom de Marisol Touraine
monsieur le rapporteur Phone lorenberg
vous avez jugé très forte
l'augmentation de l'ONDAM prévue pour
pourtant le taux retenu constitue il
faut vraiment l'affirmer un effort de
maîtrise sans précédent
entre 2007 et 2011 l'ONDA m'a progressé
de 3,3% 3,3% en moyenne par an
à comparer l'évolution de 2,1% que nous
prévoyons
monsieur le rapporteur vous évoquez des
orientations pour réduire le rythme
d'évolution des dépenses de l'ONDAM des
orientations qui il faut le dire recoupe
en partie des nôtres
mais vous fixez des objectifs plus
élevés
sans que nous ayons bien compris comment
vous proposer de vous y prendre
oui la pertinence des actes oui pour le
désorgueillement désengorgement des
urgences oui pour la meilleure gestion
du temps de travail nous les souhaitons
tous nous y travaillons mais vous le
savez il ne suffit pas de les décréter
vous le reconnaissez vous même
d'ailleurs madame Gatel ayant convenu
qu'on ne pouvait prétendre réformer d'un
claquement de doigts et donc
c'est pourtant ce qui semble ressortir
d'un certain nombre des discours
madame Doisneau sur le même sujet
vous avez avancé des chiffres
impressionnants 30 milliards d'économies
que nous pourrions faire en supprimant
les actes non pertinents
mais face à des chiffres aussi énormes
on est tenté de vous demander
pourquoi
êtes-vous resté sans rien faire face à
ces gisements d'économies je pense que
chacun en a conscience pour réduire le
nombre d'actes non pertinents il faut
des actions concrètes il faut des
actions ciblées il faut des actions
précises qui est un impact sur les
comportements des professionnels et non
pas des déclarations d'intention
marie-sol Touraine propose donc une
mesure permettant de mettre en place les
conditions d'une amélioration de la
pertinence des actes pratiqués dans les
établissements de santé
monsieur Barbier
vous avez dit
que les restructurations des
établissements de santé serait pour nous
un tabou
je veux vous rassurer
les établissements de santé publique
sont engagés au quotidien dans notre
politique ambitieuse de mise en
cohérence des structures et des
ressources avec les besoins de la
population il réalise des efforts
considérables pour leur meilleur
fonctionnement dans les contraintes
économiques qui sont aujourd'hui les
nôtres et je peux vous le confirmer
moi-même en tant que professionnel de
santé hospitalière
la restructuration n'est donc pas un
tabou pour ce gouvernement ce qu'il est
en revanche c'est le recul du service
public en matière de santé
votre plan d'économie nous semble donc
mériter bien plus que le nôtre le
qualificatif de très fragile en
particulier celui proposé par Monsieur
Delattre
il convient d'ailleurs de noter
une contradiction
mais que vous pourrez peut-être nous
expliquer entre le propos de Monsieur
Delattre qui estime que notre objectif
suppose des réformes structurelles qui
lui semblent hors de portée
permettez-nous de ne pas partager ce
pessimisme et celui de vous-même
monsieur le rapporteur qui au contraire
souhaitait faire mieux mais sans
véritablement proposer de mesures
supplémentaires
doit-on comprendre que vos propositions
c'est à dire des mesures d'économie
massive sans réforme structurelles
conduirait à l'ancienne pratique de la
majorité précédente jusqu'en 2009 à
savoir de Fort dépassement de l'ONDAM
selon les chiffres que je vous ai cités
au début et
en plus une réduction des droits
d'Assurance Maladie pour les personnes
en fixant nos dames à un niveau
irréaliste la majorité sénatoriale veut
forcer le gouvernement à des
déremboursements comme elle l'attend
pratique
vous l'avez d'ailleurs
évoqué en terme allusif monsieur le
rapporteur en nous interrogeant sur nos
choix en termes de périmètre de
l'assurance maladie et je trouve bien
légitime votre inquiétude il est très
important de pouvoir préciser
ce qui doit l'être ce qui doit être
remboursé et vous le savez nous notre ce
gouvernement et bien fait tout ce qui
est possible pour diminuer le reste à
charge pour les patients
monsieur Delattre vous le dites plus
clairement
vous appelez carrément à la
privatisation de certaines dépenses
quand un monsieur Milon vous explicitez
le modèle qui est le vôtre celui de
l'assurance privée
je note au passage
un léger défaut de cohérence au sein de
votre majorité puisque monsieur Lemoine
n'hésitez pas dans le même temps à se
prévaloir de l'héritage du Front
populaire en matière de droits sociaux
et s'inquiéter de l'affaiblissement du
consentement à l'impôt si les droits
sociaux reculés qu'il soit rassuré
le choix du gouvernement est très clair
c'est l'absence de transfert de charge
vers les patients
et Monsieur Delattre ce choix est très
majoritairement soutenu par les Français
et j'espère également par la majorité
des parlementaires
parce que nous ne croyons pas dans ce
gouvernement à la responsabilité des
patients
et non on ne se soigne pas parce que
c'est gratuit
on se soigne parce qu'on est malade et
parce qu'on en a besoin tout simplement
alors
Monsieur roche vous avez proposé la
réduction des droits en matière de
retraite
monsieur range vous tentez de nous
convaincre que l'extension des
possibilités de départ anticipées en
retraite
telle qu'elle a été décidée par Marisol
Touraine en 2012 et la mise en place du
compte pénibilité rendrait plus
acceptable le report de l'âge légal à 64
ans
la cohérence aurait supposée que les
mêmes qui ont voté votre amendement et
voter le compte pénibilité et n'est pas
encore tenté de le supprimer la semaine
dernière
je veux bien croire Monsieur roche que
vous êtes favorable à titre personnel au
compte pénibilité mais un certain nombre
de vos collègues n'ont pas votre esprit
d'équilibre et veulent donc la double
peine pour les salariés pas de compte
pénibilité et la retraite à 64 ans pour
tout le monde quel que soit la longueur
de la carrière de la personne
nous ne partageons pas dans ce
gouvernement cette idée
monsieur Savary vous vous êtes félicité
de constater que la contribution
additionnelle de solidarité pour
l'autonomie sera versée intégralement à
la Caisse nationale de solidarité pour
l'autonomie pour 2015
je le prends comme un hommage timide à
l'action du gouvernement pour
l'amélioration de notre politique
d'accompagnement des personnes
âgées dépendantes
vous le savez le projet de loi
d'adaptation à la société au
vieillissement entre en vigueur en 2015
enfin je l'espère quand il sera passé
chez vous
il renforcera la location personnalisée
d'autonomie là pas pour favoriser le
maintien à domicile des personnes et je
pense que nous pouvons sur ces questions
là trouver un accord global sur
l'ensemble de ces bancs il permettra de
renforcer la prévention de la dépendance
il donnera un statut aux personnes qui
aident aux aidants et renforcera le
droit des personnes âgées en situation
de vulnérabilité
vous m'avez également demandé vous avez
demandé à Marisol Touraine où nous en
étions du travail sur les établissements
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes ce qu'on appelle les EHPAD
le groupe de travail qui avait été
annoncé à commencer à travailler il est
animé par un membre de l'IGAS et réunit
à la fois des administrations et les
principaux partenaires concernés afin de
travailler autour de trois axes
principaux
d'abord moderniser l'allocation de
ressources ensuite améliorer les
pratiques de contractualisation et de
dialogues de gestion sur la base
d'indicateurs de qualité et de
performance enfin définir les
prestations d'hébergement et les
prestations supplémentaires délivrées
dans ces établissements des hébergement
pour personnes âgées dépendantes
pour les personnes âgées dépendantes et
les personnes en situation de handicap
vous avez raison de dire Monsieur Jean
Sanitas que les forces poursuit
nous continuons de créer des places et
d'investir dans la rénovation des
structures
nous rattrapons notre retard en matière
de prise en charge de l'autisme nous
expérimentons la mise en oeuvre de
parcours de soins et d'accompagnement
complet sans rupture des personnes âgées
dépendantes
j'en viens désormais à la famille
madame cailleux vous avez posé des
questions précises sur la modulation
j'ai apporterai des réponses lors de
l'examen de l'article 61
mais je veux répondre dès maintenant à
la fois aux propos de Madame cailloux
sur le déficit de la branche famille et
de Monsieur Delattre sur les ressources
de la branche famille
notre gouvernement
a affecté à la branche famille
l'intégralité du produit de
l'abaissement du quotient familial et à
compenser l'intégralité des diminutions
des cotisations familiales
il n'y a pas de baisse des recettes de
la branche famille pas plus qu'il n'y a
de gestion empirique et comptable de la
branche au détriment des familles comme
vous l'avez dit Madame cailleux le
gouvernement préserve les ressources de
la politique familiale pour la
moderniser et pour l'adapter aux besoins
actuels des familles
on doit pouvoir introduire des nuances
dans nos politiques et mieux cibler les
aides que la sécurité sociale verse aux
familles sans être caricaturalement
accusé de mettre à bas la politique
familiale sans quoi on ne ferait plus
rien comme la bien indiquée madame
meunier
l'universalité au cœur de la politique
familiale française ni nullement remise
en cause toutes les familles de deux
enfants ou plus continueront à
bénéficier des allocations familiales
toutefois le principe d'universalité des
droits n'excluent nullement de tenir
compte des ressources et de la situation
réelle des familles dans le versement
des aides madame meunier vous avez tout
à fait résumé le principe d'action du
gouvernement en matière de politique
familiale
monsieur Derio
je dois répondre
à votre
insinuation quant au fait que la branche
à TMP serait une variable d'ajustement
pour équilibrer la branche maladie
si tel était le cas que n'avons nous
fixé la compensation de la
sous-déclaration des accidents du
travail à la borne haute proposée par la
Commission d'évaluation de 300 millions
d'euros supérieurs au montant que nous
avons retenu
vous soulevez par ailleurs le sujet de
l'ouverture d'une voix individuelle de
la caata le rapport du Gouvernement sur
ce sujet sera remis le 20 décembre
prochain je souhaite qu'ils servent de
base à notre discussion sur l'équilibre
de ce dispositif qui témoigne de la
solidarité du pays pour les travailleurs
exposés au risque de l'amiante
nous avons d'ailleurs eu ici même un
débat très intéressant sur les risques
liés à la molente avec un travail
sénatorial de grande qualité il y a très
peu de temps
la ministre a noté avec satisfaction que
beaucoup de vos interventions anticipent
les débats que vous aurez au moment de
la discussion sur la loi de santé
cela témoigne d'une attente voire d'une
certaine impatience cela renforce la
détermination
et l'ambition de Marisol Touraine pour
cette loi qui aura un impact très
positif sur la vie quotidienne des
Français
la généralisation du tiers payant en
sera la réalisation majeure
vous commencez
le travail de caricature de cette mesure
qui permettra aux Français de ne plus
avancer le prix d'une consultation chez
le médecin
vous avez qualifié cela d'une mesure
d'assistanat
de l'assistanat tout de même pensez pas
que vous avez une notion un petit peu
extensive
ne devoir ne pas devoir avancer les
frais plutôt que d'avancer et d'être
remboursé avec délai c'est être un
assisté pour vous améliorer le service
rendu par l'assurance maladie
obligatoire pour laquelle chaque
Français cotise c'est encouragé
l'assistanat
monsieur Cardou il faut savoir qu'il y a
un certain nombre de personnes qui ne
vont pas consulter parce qu'elles n'ont
pas les moyens d'avancer l'argent c'est
tout simplement ça et plus on attend
pour aller consulter plus la pathologie
sera grave et plus les frais seront
importants par la suite
comme Madame Génisson la rappeler la
généralisation du tiers payant est
conforme au projet de progrès social que
porte le gouvernement
en améliorant la qualité et la
performance de notre sécurité sociale
obligatoire et en refusant le recul des
droits
monsieur de César et Madame David
ont indiqué leurs inquiétudes sur le
recours au droit des plus fragiles
c'est un souci que nous partageons et la
ministre de la santé prend des mesures
pour lutter contre le non recours ainsi
que d'ailleurs l'ensemble de l'équipe
des affaires sociales
nous étions le bénéfice du tiers payant
au bénéficiaire de la CS afin de
favoriser leur recours aux soins la loi
de l'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement permettra le
renouvellement automatique de l'aide à
la complémentaire santé pour les
bénéficiaires de l'allocation spécifique
pour les personnes âgées
nous soutenons les démarches de
simplification dans les caisses de
sécurité sociale et les administrations
sociales pour rendre l'accès aux droits
plus facile et nous présenterons dans
les prochaines semaines la version
aboutie du simulateur des droits sociaux
dont le projet a été dévoilé par le
Président de la République le 30 octobre
dernier
le simulateur permettra de savoir très
rapidement et de façon fiable en
fonction de sa situation personnelle
l'ensemble des droits sociaux auxquels
chacun a droit
alors pour terminer je voudrais
citer monsieur dodini le sénateur de
Dini qui l'a dit qui a dit
le texte
que nous présentons ici que le
Gouvernement présente comporte de
nombreuses mesures de justice
l'examen des articles confortera cette
appréciation incontestable
on écoute la ministre là
merci merci
Madame le Ministre la discussion
générale
est close
vous voulez
oui monsieur le ministre si vous
souhaitez intervenir vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais aussi apporter un certain
nombre de réponses aux interventions
auxquelles j'ai eu le plaisir d'assister
en
commençant peut-être par remercier
l'ensemble des orateurs pour la qualité
du débat mais aussi en partageant le
constat du rapporteur général selon
lequel j'ai bien entendu la France était
entrée dans la crise avec un déficit
structurelle élevé en 2008 faut-il le
rappeler c'est à dire avant que l'on
constate les effets de la crise sur les
finances publiques le déficit était déjà
de 9,3 milliards d'euros
9,3 milliards d'euros c'était en effet
handicap considérable dont nous payons
aujourd'hui le prix
Jean-Noël Cardou nous invite à
relativiser l'héritage je pense au
contraire qu'il faut avoir le courage de
l'assumer à sa vraie valeur
certes les recettes dans ce pdfss sont
été révisées comme chaque fois que le
gouvernement a eu de nouvelles
indications sur la conjoncture
économique en effet alors que les
dépenses sont parfaitement tenues ce
sont les recettes qui ont été moins
élevées que prévu et dans les faits se
retrouvent directement dans les contes
je rappelle aussi que pour 2015 ce ne
sont pas des mesures de recettes qui
permettent une réduction de 2 milliards
d'euros du déficit mais seulement les
mesures d'économie d'où en effet la
modicité apparente de la réduction du
déficit mais cette baisse de 2 milliards
d'euros du déficit doit être préservé
pour autant je ne peux laisser dire et
je m'adresse aussi à Monsieur Delattre
ainsi qu'à d'autres orateurs
que nos prévisions 2015 seraient
irréalistes ou contredites par le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques je le dis
avec beaucoup d'humilité madame monsieur
le sénateur malgré tous les services
spécialisés qui a pu le gouvernement
nous nous risquerons à annoncer les
prévisions au mieux nos connaissances et
possibilités parce que les lois
organiques nous y obligent et pour
donner à tous de la lisibilité mais ces
prévisions doivent parfois être révisées
le gouvernement peut soutenir la
comparaison avec ce qui s'est fait dans
toutes les lois de finances précédentes
ainsi je vous rappelle quand PLF pour
2012 la prévision de croissance était de
1,75 au moment du dépôt et qu'elle s'est
en réalité avérée atteindre seulement
0,3 pour cent
, je pense que nous pouvons nous
accorder sur le fait que l'exercice est
difficile et qu'il ne serait pas
bienvenue de donner des leçons au
gouvernement actuel en matière de
prévision
s'agissant de la dette accumulée par la
cause que le Rapporteur général a évoqué
certaines n'est pas amortie mais la
situation actuelle sur les taux de court
terme durablement bas ne constituent ni
une menace ni un pari vous l'avez
rappelé il faudrait augmenter la CRDS
gouvernement préfère quant à lui réduire
les prélèvements sociaux et réaliser
dans le même temps des mesures
d'économie
s'agissant précisément de ces économies
monsieur
vend leur Bergen vous nous dites enfin
que douter de la réalité
de l'engagement vous nous dites douter
de la réalité de l'engagement du
gouvernement les mener je ne peux que le
regretter j'ai précisément détaillé les
9,6 milliards d'euros d'économie
j'ajoute donc quelques précisions qui
seront je l'espère de nature à lever vos
doutes ainsi concernant les 600 millions
d'euros de la branche famille issue de
mesure passées et prise en compte non
seulement l'impact évaluer à 300
millions d'euros des mesures votées en
LFS pour 2014 mais également l'impact en
2015 de la pérennisation de l'économie
résultant de la moindre consommation du
FNAS constatée en 2013
vous évoquez aussi des économies de
régime gérés par les partenaires sociaux
s'agit pour environ 400 millions d'euros
d'économies de constatation de
constatation
réalisée sur les dépenses de l'inédit en
je tiens à souligner que cet effort de
redressement des comptes se fait
uniquement par des économies en dépense
comme nous nous irions engagés et
certains d'entre vous l'ont souligné je
remercie notamment madame Gatel à cet
égard
le rapporteur pour la vie de la
commission des finances monsieur
Delattre
avant ce que la solution équitable sur
les dividendes que ce verse les chefs
d'entreprise en guise de rémunération
serait de les soumettre à cotisations
pour la seule part inférieure au plafond
de la sécurité sociale je ne peux pas
être d'accord cela reviendrait à
introduire une notion de contributivité
qui n'est pas de mise sur ce sujet ce
débat sera appelé à se poursuivre
vous appelez de vos vœux monsieur le
Président de la Commission de l'affaire
sociale une réforme du financement de la
protection sociale vous savez que la
diversification des ressources a déjà
été entreprises par ailleurs le Haut
Conseil de financement de la protection
sociale a précisément été saisi d'une
feuille de route le 21 octobre dernier
incluant une réflexion sur
l'architecture et la gouvernance
financière de la protection sociale qui
viendra compléter les travaux déjà menés
l'année dernière
monsieur daudini vous avez appelé le
soutien de cette assemblée à l'emploi à
domicile et le vote et le vote unanime
de la Haute Assemblée pour l'emploi à
domicile je vous ai fait part de mon
intervention liminaire lundi des raisons
pour lesquelles le gouvernement a
proposé à l'Assemblée la mesure plus
ciblée que celle-ci a adopté nous ne
souhaitons pas modifier les paramètres
de cette mesure en raison du coût qui en
résulterait et dégraderait le solde des
régimes sociaux monsieur des Essarts
nous dit que ce sont les économies sur
la sphère sociale qui compenserait les
effets du pacte mais ce n'est pas le cas
il est simple de s'en assurer l'adoption
du pacte ne modifie pas en aucune
manière les trajectoires de réduction
des déficits de la Sécurité sociale
l'état compense le pacte à l'euro près
les économies qui sont réalisées dans le
champ de la protection sociale reste au
sein de la sphère sociale ce sont elles
qui permettent de poursuivre la
réduction du déficit et il n'y a pas de
captation par l'État
de même vous critiquez la suppression du
transfert des produits de l'exit tax je
souhaite rectifier un point il
s'agissait d'un transfert de recettes de
l'État à la sécurité sociale sans
rapport avec des sommes recouvrées mais
également sans rapport avec les sommes
réellement dues puisque celle-ci était
connu uniquement plus tard le mécanisme
de calcul impliqué en effet que les
montants transférés avant même le
recouvrement sont plusieurs dizaines de
fois plus élevées que les sommes perçues
le transfert se fera désormais sur la
base des sommes perçues ce qui est tout
à fait logique s'agissons toujours des
recettes monsieur Cardou à qualifié de
je cite mesure à la petite semaine la
réforme de recouvrement sur les caisses
de congés payés là encore ce n'est pas
parce qu'une mesure n'a défait que
temporaire qu'il faut s'abstenir de la
réaliser surtout quand elle représente 2
milliards d'euros sur deux ans je
rappelle aussi qu'un s'inscrit dans la
suite des dispositions prises en 2013
madame David vous considérez pour votre
part que le nouveau mode de calcul de la
CG sur les revenus de remplacement
pénalisera là je vous cite les retraités
je suis un peu surpris
vous oubliez en effet de dire que cette
réforme avantage beaucoup les retraités
les plus modestes qui vont passer du
taux normal au taux réduit et que seuls
les retraités plus aisés qui bénéficient
de réduction de crédit d'impôts feront
le passage inverse auront le temps
d'échanger sur l'intérêt de cette mesure
et je l'espère nous aurons le temps de
vous convaincre vous avez aussi madame
David évoqué l'ampleur de la fraude aux
cotisations sociales vous nous reprochez
de réduire
les effectifs mais ce n'est pas exact
nous avons seulement non seulement
maintenu les effectifs des inspecteurs
des urssafs chargés de cette mission
importante mais en plus ceux-ci se sont
accrus puisqu'un corps de contrôleurs du
recouvrement a été créé et ajouté aux
inspecteurs du recouvrement
cela témoigne de l'attention
particulière accordée à la lutte contre
les fraudes dans un contexte de
recherche pourtant d'économie voilà
Mesdames Messieurs le sénateur je suis
conscient de ne pas répondre à
l'ensemble des points soulevés par les
orateurs mais nous aurons je n'en doute
pas le temps de revenir sur la plupart
des de ces points au cours du débat
merci
merci monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues la discussion
générale et close nous passons à la
discussion de la motion tentante à
opposer la question préalable
madame Laurence Cohen et les membres du
groupe communiste républicains et
citoyen ont déposé une mention une
motion distribuée sous le numéro
324 pendant à opposer la question
préalable au texte en discussion
madame Cohen vous avez la parole ma
chère collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
les interventions générales ont donné le
temps marqué le début de l'examen de ce
nouveau PLFSS le troisième que nous
examinons depuis que Madame Touraine et
ministre de la Santé et malheureusement
nous sommes une fois de plus très
inquiets par son contenu certes quelques
dispositions vont dans le bon sens je
pense notamment à la prévention qu'il
s'agisse du dépistage du VIH à l'article
33 ou de l'accès à la vaccination à
l'article 34 je remarque également avec
intérêt la volonté du gouvernement de
renforcer les dispositions prises depuis
décembre 2012 pour tenter de faire échec
au désert médicaux mais la structure
même de ce budget sa conception nous ont
conduit à déposer cette motion pour nous
les choix de réduction budgétaire pour
ne pas dire au séritaire qui ont guidé
l'élaboration de ce budget sont
contraires à une politique devant
renforcer notre système de protection
sociale et sonne petit à petit année
après année le glas de la sécurité
sociale
en ce sens nous estimons qu'il n'y a pas
lieu de débattre d'un budget qui
entérine la mort annoncé de notre
système de protection sociale mis en
place en 1945 et nous ne pouvons que
constater avec colère ou pour le moins
une certaine amertume combien la
différence est grande avec le PLFSS pour
2012 examiné en 2011 année où le Sénat
venait de basculer à gauche et où cette
nouvelle majorité adoptait
collectivement des amendements pour
proposer des financements justes et
pérennes permettant de répondre au
déficit structurel de la sécurité
sociale pourquoi ne pas avoir poursuivi
dans cette voie pire ce PLFSS aux
attaquer à l'un des piliers de notre
système en mettant fin à l'universalité
des prestations familiales dans la
continuité des voilà nous quittons
l'hémicycle ou les sénateurs continuent
de débattre du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2015 vous avez pu notamment entendre les
secrétaires d'État Ségolène Neuville
Christian Eckert secrétaire d'État au
budget également et bien Laurence Cohen
signatrice communiste qui était en train
de défendre une motion des communistes
qui estiment que ce projet de loi et
bien c'est la mort annoncé de notre
système de protection sociale rappelons
que il va y avoir de nombreux débats ici
au Sénat notamment autour de la
modulation des allocations familiales
une des mesures phares de ce texte
mesure que la droite majoritaire au
Sénat et que les communistes également
souhaitent rejeter tout de suite et bien
on va rejoindre la salle Clémenceau ou
le ministre de l'Agriculture Stéphane Le
Foll est auditionné par les sénateurs de
la commission des affaires économiques
cela sur le projet de loi de finances
pour 2015 et sur les crédits de
l'agriculture rappelons que ces crédits
sont en baisse de 4% et que cela fait
déjà plusieurs années que le ministère
de l'agriculture doit se serrer la
ceinture tout de suite donc direction la
salle Clémenceau
bien écoutez monsieur le ministre sont
évidemment très heureux de vous
accueillir ici dans le cadre de la
préparation du projet de loi de finances
2015 qui sera discuté dans quelques
semaines d'ici et nous allons vous
entendre sur les crédits qui sont
inscrits sur la mission agriculture
alimentation forêt à faire rurales ce
qui représente un portefeuille
considérable alors d'une façon générale
avant de donner la parole d'abord à
chaque représentant des groupes
politiques et ensuite aux intervenants
qui souhaitent dire un mot je dirais que
la première observation que nous faisons
c'est que les crédits de paiement
registres encore une fois une diminution
cette diminution étant particulièrement
importante cette année vous allez bien
sûr nous expliquer pourquoi notamment
pour ces concernent l'enveloppe
budgétaire de France à Grimmer
en revanche une constatons également les
autorisations d'engagement progressent
pour financer de nouvelles actions vous
allez évidemment nous dire lesquels
permettez-moi simplement de vous poser
deux questions et vous donner deux
informations les deux questions sont les
suivantes l'application
du mécanisme de discipline budgétaire
entraîne une réduction des aides
directes au-delà d'un certain montant or
pour la campagne 2014 la Commission
européenne propose à nouveau une
réduction des paiements directs pour
alimenter la réserve de crise qui est
presque épuisée à cause de l'embargo
russe donc est-ce que la France a pris
des initiatives avec d'autres États et
qu'en est-il aujourd'hui seconde
question la réduction des ressources des
chambres d'agriculture nous entendons
évidemment beaucoup parler je n'insiste
pas au-delà d'autres le feront les deux
informations
la Commission à faire d'économique
devant laquelle vous êtes appris deux
initiatives tout d'abord de créer un
groupe de travail consacré aux normes
dans l'agriculture norme sanitaire et
environnementales donc ce groupe va
rassembler des représentants des
différentes formations politiques
présentes dans cette commission et nous
allons y travailler d'arrache-pied très
rapidement et deuxièmement nous avons
créé un comité de suivi nous allons du
moins créer un comité de suivi avec la
Commission des vers de terre européennes
pour ce qui est de l'application de la
politique agricole commune voilà
Monsieur le Ministre quelques
observations que vous voulez faire en
préambule maintenant ne vous écoutons
c'est pas je peux continuer de parler
mais je pense que le mieux c'est non non
le mieux c'est que vous d'accord
moi ce président d'abord moi je réponds
à l'invitation c'est un débat important
sur les questions budgétaires je vais
pas revenir sur le contexte que vous
connaissez le ministère de l'Agriculture
s'inscrit dans les forces global qui est
demandé au budget de la nation de
réduction de la dépense de l'État et de
réduction surtout déficit budgétaire bon
ce budget va donc baisser en crédit de
paiement vous l'avez souligné à 4,7
milliards d'euros ce qui fait une baisse
d'environ 4% à hauteur de en valeur
absolue 200 millions d'euros
le débat sur la loi d'avenir qu'on a eu
ici au Sénat comme à l'Assemblée portait
aussi en partie sur les grandes
questions liées à la compétitivité du
secteur je rappelle que dans ce cadre là
pour l'année 2015 l'ensemble des mesures
du pacte de responsabilité
qui porte à la fois sur le cice plus les
allègements de charge sur les basses à
l'air vont représenter à L2 pour le
secteur agricole agroalimentaire et
forestier gros employeur près de 730
millions d'euros donc si je fais la
différence entre la baisse en crédit de
paiement que vous avez noté et
l'engagement qui va bénéficier au
travers du pack de responsabilité à
l'agriculture à l'agroalimentaire on a
un solde positif de l'effort de l'État
en transfert de près de 530 millions
d'euros
même si
c'est un débat que nous pouvons avoir
cette baisse liée au pack de
responsabilité c'est un élément de la
compétitivité je peux le dire je l'ai
constaté dans un stand de domaine sur ça
c'est certain nombre de sujets si je
prends par exemple l'abattoir Gad en
Bretagne qui a failli fermer s'il y
avait pas du crédit d'impôts et les
avances de crise d'impôt je peux vous
dire qu'on n'aurait pas fait la jonction
avec le repreneur aujourd'hui je pense
cet exemple il y en a plein d'autres
c'est aussi un effort qui est fait pour
par exemple l'école nationale
vétérinaire de Maisons-Alfort de 5
millions sur 6 ans le président du Sénat
vous en remercie qui a été fait je suis
même rendu la semaine dernière dans
cette école et j'ai vu que c'est vrai
que le conseil d'administration ça m'a
été dit par son président avait changé
de tonalité il y a vraiment maintenant
des objectifs sur lequel ils vont
pouvoir s'engager il y a aussi dans
cette dans ce budget une priorité qui
était très importante pour ce qui me
concernait depuis longtemps c'est en
sanitaire puisque pour la première fois
on va voir des créations nettes
positives de postes à hauteur de 60
postes pour les le sanitaires et ça je
vous le rappelle quand je suis arrivé on
a limité de moitié la baisse des
effectifs qui étaient prévus à 120 et on
l'a ramené à 60 l'an dernier on a
stabilisé le les effectifs sur les
contrôles sanitaires vétérinaires et
cette année pour la première fois on
crée 60 postes vous savez que des
rapports de la Cour des comptes des
rapports au niveau de l'olivet aussi
nécessité qu'on soit extrêmement
vigilant et que sur ce sujet là on
revienne avec une politique plus
offensive et plus ambitieuse c'est aussi
dans le cadre des grands choix
stratégiques liés à France agrimaire en
particulier une politique sur la
modernisation qui fait que l'État voit
l'engagement qu'il prend pour la
modernisation des exploitations
agricoles en même temps
qu'on le fait avec les régions et la
mobilisation du fait Ader son budget
augmenté à 56 millions d'euros par
rapport aux 30 millions d'euros de
l'année précédente c'est sur
les questions liées en particulier
à France agrimaire le fait que sur le
budget tel qu'il était conçu on bascule
vers
l'utilisation et la mobilisation de près
de 120 millions sur les pays a
120 millions c'est important c'est une
stratégie d'investissement pour France
agrimaire qui même si je le dis son
budget proprement dit tel qu'il était
conçu l'année précédente ou les années
précédentes change puisque là on
mobilise de l'argent du pays mais ça
reste un budget opérationnel lié à
l'investissement je pense que ça c'est
important ça vaut d'ailleurs aussi pour
les moyens d'investissement de la
politique forestière ensuite il y a dans
ce budget aussi le fait que on soit en
parfaite cohérence avec le discours de
Cournon sur le soutien à l'élevage et je
voudrais rappeler quand même là qu'on va
atteindre le milliard 100 millions
d'euros
globale pour l'élevage d'ici 2016
c'est-à-dire bien avant les l'objectif
de 2018 qui avait été celui qui avait
fixé le président de la République dans
son discours de Cournon et dès l'année
2015 on va sur les enjeux liés à lycée à
chaîne à la fusion Phu arrivée à
pratiquement 928 millions d'euros pour
l'élevage pour toutes ces zones
concernées par les zones de handicap
naturel j'ai vu quelques députés j'en ai
discuté avec quelques sénateurs c'est
vrai que dans toutes ces zones c'est que
reconnu même par la profession agricole
comme un élément extrêmement positif je
rajouterai aussi que on a continué la
stratégie liée à l'agroécologie débat
qui a beaucoup animé les nuits au moment
d'une discussion sur la loi d'avenir à
la fois sur les groupements latéraux
économiques sur les groupements
d'intérêt économiques environnementaux
qu'on a créé dans le cadre de la forêt
et là on maintient
les les moyens du casse d'art qui est
même augmenté de 125 à 147 millions
d'euros pour justement engager une
politique dans ce sens parce que je
crois beaucoup avec en plus les maeux et
puis la bio je crois beaucoup
qu'aujourd'hui si on veut sortir de la
logique de la norme environnementale qui
s'applique et qui rend le travail des
agriculteurs difficiles il faut qu'on
soit capable de porter un projet
cohérent en termes économique et en
termes environnemental c'est tout
l'enjeu de ladroécologie et je sais que
là dessus les discussions qu'on a eu ont
été suffisamment approfondies pour que
sur dans ce domaine on puisse mettre en
oeuvre les choses je l'annonce devant la
commission aussi le 15 janvier on aura
une journée complète sur l'agroécologie
on fera la photo une de la France de
l'agroécologie et avec la perspective
que j'avais indiqué lors d'un colloque
de l'INRA sur l'objectif de basculer 50%
des exploitations agricoles françaises
d'ici 2025 dans l'agroécologie et le 15
janvier on fixera les critères sur
lesquels on va s'appuyer justement pour
basculer de ce côté là je sais aussi
qu'il va y avoir bien entendu des
discussions sur un certain nombre de
sujets j'ajoute oui un point dans le
cadre de la politique sanitaire ce qui
avait été demandé d'ailleurs au Sénat
ici par rapport à l'ancêtre si vous
savez qu'une partie des autorisations
mise en marché
sont ont basculés du côté de l'ancêtre
débats qu'on avait eu réticence il
fallait surtout donner les moyens à
l'encens aura les moyens d'assumer
puisqu'on a des plafonnés le plafond
d'emploi pour l'encens et puis on l'a
doté de 10 et TP supplémentaires dès
2015 pour pouvoir justement assurer à
l'encens les moyens qui vont être
nécessaires à cette nouvelle mission sur
les autorisations mise en marché j'ai
d'ailleurs en même temps que je visitais
l'école nationale de Maison-Alfort vu le
site et le lieu où va être installé dans
ces modèles nouveau
qui va lui donner dans ces toutes les
conditions pour bien travailler et bien
répondre aux objectifs qu'on s'était
fixés dans le débat parlementaire dans
la loutre dans le cadre de la loi
d'avenir bon il y a des efforts qui sont
demandés c'est bien sûr là que il y aura
des discussions à la fois sur les postes
qui ont été créés certes je l'ai rappelé
dans la recherche dans l'enseignement
technique et aussi dans le contrôle
vétérinaire
240 postes de créer mais c'est aussi des
suppressions de 225 postes c'est aussi
des efforts de demander aux opérateurs
ça vaut en particulier pour l'ONF avec
une renégociation du coq qui va être
engagée et qui a commencé et puis ça
vaut aussi pour les établissements
publics en particulier des chambres
d'agriculture puisque tout le monde est
mis avec le CNPF aussi sur tout le monde
est mis sur les mêmes normes en termes
de fonds de roulement c'est-à-dire la
règle prudentielle c'est deux mois de
fondrement tout ce qui est au-dessus
sert à économiser
transactions et du budget de l'État on
est dans cette phase difficile donc ça
vaut pour les chambres de l'agriculture
ça vaut aussi pour le CNPF c'est vrai ça
c'est des efforts il y aura sûrement
mais je répondais aux questions un débat
sur le contrat vendange aussi mais je le
rappelle l'ensemble du pack de
responsabilité parce que ça c'est quand
même important ça sera 730 millions
d'euros de plus qui viendra soutenir la
compétitivité de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire de manière générale
monsieur le Président je termine en
répondant à une des questions que vous
avez posées sur l'embargo russe que fait
la France sur
la question de l'embargorus vous savez
qu'il y a un débat au niveau de la
Commission européenne qui consiste à
dire que le financement des mesures
nécessaires pour éviter que l'embargorus
et des conséquences dramatiques sur les
filières agricoles devaient être prélevé
sur le fond de gestion de crise le vrai
problème et vous l'avez très bien dit
c'est que ce vont se fondent gestion de
crise c'est un prélèvement sur le
premier pilier
et que si on consomme cette année ce
fond de gestion de 440 millions d'euros
ça veut dire qu'il faudra prélever
l'année prochaine sur le premier pilier
si on veut réalimenter ce fond nous ne
l'acceptons pas la France à mon
initiative a pris l'initiative d'une
déclaration lors du conseil des
ministres de lundi déclaration qui a été
signée par 21 pays donc ça fait 22 pays
avec la France 21 pays dont le dernier
c'était le matin quand je suis arrivé le
ministre polonais du voir pour me dire
qui signait ce qui était quand même pas
évident
pour lui parce qu'il a fallu qu'il se
cale avec son ministre des Finances j'ai
vu aussi le ministre allemand qui
ne signant pas la lettre a quand même
dit de manière publique qui soutenait la
déclaration de la France et des 21 pays
donc il est parfaitement conscient parce
qu'il y a un sujet sur lequel on est en
train de se battre j'ai été voir genre
Arthur après président de la commission
budgétaire du Parlement parce qu'il faut
avoir les deux puisque c'est une
conciliation qui est engagée
pour dire la chose suivante dans les
sanctions qui sont appliquées au niveau
européen il y a une part de sanctions
agricoles liée en particulier au
dépassement des quotas laitiers dans le
cadre de ce qu'on appelle l'atterrissage
en douceur avec la fin des quotas
laitiers pour 2015
ces sanctions qui ont été payées par des
agriculteurs pas français
allemand Autrichiens Pays-Bas Irlande
Danemark
polonais
ces sanctions et ses paiements c'est
sanctions donc c'est sanctions
financières qui représentent autour de
400 millions d'euros aujourd'hui bien
sûr les budgétaires de l'Europe veulent
les récupérer dans le paquet global du
budget donc la déclaration que nous
avons faite lundi c'est dire non le
titre de doit être utilisé pour financer
les mesures de l'embargo russe 21 pays
22 juillet avec la France et le soutien
d'ailleurs de la présidence italienne
qui a pris la déclaration des 22 pays
comme position du Conseil et qu'il l'a
transmise au Conseil des ministres des
Finances puisque c'est ça l'enjeu c'est
de faire en sorte qu'on soit soutenu
maintenant dans le débat budgétaire
entre le Parlement et la Commission le
Parlement et le Conseil des ministres
des Finances sur cette ligne qui
consiste tout simplement à dire que les
sanctions qui ont été payées par les
agriculteurs sur l'année 2014 pour les
dépassements de côté reviennent le
budget de l'agriculture en particulier
pour financer les mesures de
l'embargorie pour justement ne pas
pomper le fond de gestion de crise et
éviter que l'année prochaine on soit
dans une situation non seulement les
prix serait bas pour les agriculteurs
l'embargorie sur un impact et en plus on
se trouve obligé de baisser les aides
pour pouvoir financer les mesures de
l'embargo ça c'est un sujet
politiquement qui a nécessité notre
mobilisation donc je vous le dis
monsieur le Président lundi il y a eu ce
texte qui a été signé par 22 pays et qui
a été repris par la
par la présidente italienne
ensuite il y avait un sujet sur les
normes c'est très bien que le Sénat se
saisisse de ce sujet on a nommé une
mission avec une députée Frédéric Massat
et puis une
fonctionnaire et
le
Bastien voilà l'ancien de la Chambre
d'Agriculture d'Alsace pour travailler
non pas sur le fait qu'il y ait plus de
contrôle parce que ça on ne pourra pas
le faire mais pour faire en sorte que
ces contrôles soient mieux ordonnés
mieux coordonnées éviter qu'il se
multiplie et qu'il donne l'impression
aux agriculteurs de subir ainsi une
suspicion continue puis en même temps
essayer de faire en sorte que avec la
mise en place de la nouvelle pack en
soit dans une politique d'acceptabilité
des contrôles et d'explications aussi de
ce qui va se passer parce que c'est
toujours j'en suis désolé je peux pas
vous dire autre chose mais c'est vrai
que c'est toujours compliqué quand vous
avez 9,1
millions d'euros à 9 milliards sans
d'euros à distribuer avec des règles qui
sont compliquées que ça soit sous le
premier pilier le deuxième pilier les la
partie du verdissement on a besoin
d'avoir un temps à la fois de contrôle
parce que il faudrait pas comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui avoir des apurements
demain et moi je paye aujourd'hui des
spécialistes 600 millions d'euros sur
des apurements entre les aides qui ont
été versées entre 2006 et 2010 plus 350
millions d'euros pour 2011 et 2012-2012
parce que les calculs qu'on avait fait à
l'époque était pas suffisamment précis
et l'Europe vient nous redemander des
voilà le rembourser ce qu'on a distribué
alors donc ça fait à peu près un peu oui
950 millions de Total et encore ce qui
était prévu par la commission je vous le
dis au passage c'était 4 milliards et
demi
on a ramené ça
et on a bien travaillé je remercie les
services là on a ramené ça à à peine un
milliard
donc moi je veux pas laisser à mes
successeurs quel qu'il soit d'ailleurs
des apurements comme ça il vaut mieux
être clair mais en même temps il faut
faire des contrôles mais il faut que ça
soit accepté donc c'est je vous invite
donc la mission a été lancée et c'est
très bien que le Sénat se saisisse de ce
sujet il faut qu'on essaie à l'esprit
oui il faut des contrôles parce que
sinon ça peut pas marcher mais oui il
faut aussi qu'on soit capable de faire
en sorte de mieux se débrouiller pour
que on multiplie pas les contrôles le
Neymar a un moment la MSA ensuite le
contrôle pas qu'ensuite ça fait trois
contrôles quelquefois la même année qui
se succèdent on pourrait quand même
réfléchir à coordonner nos actions et à
éviter que les agriculteurs c'est ce que
disait tout à l'heure se sentent soumis
à un contrôle systématique voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire Monsieur le
Président l'introduction bien merci
Monsieur ministre simplement pour
rebondir sur le dernier point en ce qui
concerne les normes le groupe de travail
va s'intéresser alors c'est un groupe
qui a été créé à l'initiative de Dubois
goût va s'intéresser évidemment à la
façon dont les contrôles vont exécuter
mais aux normes elles-mêmes que de
contrôle ça veut dire qu'il y a des
normes et il est vrai que dans certains
territoires on est près de la Jacquerie
par rapport à des contrôles qui ont été
faits selon des modalités surprenantes
pour le siècle où nous sommes alors nous
allons demander à chaque groupe
politique de faire intervenir l'un des
siens je crois que c'est Frédéric
espanac qui va intervenir pour
après gérard César bien sûr
moi nous sommes tous les deux côte à
côte et nous entendons très bien vu on a
vu ça
oui allez gérard César voilà
première question monsieur le ministre
les champs de ma culture
l'inquiétude champs de culture les 45
millions de prélèvements et alors que
j'ai mon voisin qui est juste à côté de
moi qui me dit moi j'ai fait des
provisions pour la construction
l'aménagement de mon de mon siège et
aujourd'hui on vient de me prélever
l'argent que j'ai mis de côté
méticuleusement et après année donc
c'est une c'est une une demande que je
vous fais monsieur le ministre par
rapport à l'inquiétude des chambres et
culture deuxième question très rapide
concernant les les crédits concernant
l'assurance aléa climatique
c'est vrai que l'objectif du
gouvernement nous l'avons noté était de
faire progresser depuis plusieurs années
le taux de couverture donc au niveau de
l'assurance mais avec des crédits en
baisse le taux réel de subvention ne
risque pas de passer de 65 % à 50 %
comme l'aspect et comment espérer rendre
la l'assurance attractive dans ces
conditions troisième question très
rapide vous en avez parlé dans votre
exposé luminaire le président aussi en a
parlé français
en particulier avec en cas de crise
comment seront provisionnés justement
les crédits de France agrimaire en cas
de crise conjoncturelle et la question
que je voulais opposer en sous question
que pensez-vous de la marche de
l'Observatoire des prix et les marches
que nous avons voté dans la LMA à
l'époque et je sais que Daniel Dubois
est très attentif une autre question
concernant en particulier
la politique forestière c'est vrai que
le président le roi était ici à
l'instant il doit être encore là
ça pose problème du fond stratégique qui
a été adopté justement dans la loi
d'avenir c'est important de souligner et
justement ce qui est important c'est de
souligner justement le financement de se
font stratégique bois si on veut
vraiment avoir une politique cohérente
pour la forêt dernière question le
contrat vendanges
qui puisse se poser ces questions ne le
faisons ensemble et de la même voix les
inquiétudes justement par rapport à la
diminution justement des exorations des
charges salariales par rapport à ce
qu'on travaille en sachant que
malheureusement si c'est contrats
n'existent plus ça va favoriser le
travail au noir et c'est pas Jean-Claude
que je dis ça mais tout ça pour vous
dire que ce qui est important
aujourd'hui c'est que ce sont des
étudiants des ouvriers aussi des gens en
congé qui demandent pas de prestation et
qui pourrait et qui bénéficie et qui
rendent service justement à la
viticulture voilà Monsieur le Ministre
quelques questions très rapidement
posées merci Gérard j'espère que tout le
monde fera pareil au niveau du rythme
on va laisser passer donc les quatre
interventions Frédéric Espana pour le
groupe socialiste
étant donné que le maximum de questions
déjà été posée je vais faire très courte
j'ai juste en faire en complément
j'aurais juste en Avant Propos monsieur
le ministre déjà vous vous remercier
pour ce que vous avez fait sur l'embargo
russe et ce qui a été fait au niveau
européen ces derniers jours dire aussi
que j'ai auditionné tout à l'heure là on
sait c'est donc du coup par rapport à ce
que vous avez dit confirmer ce que vous
avez dit à savoir le côté
par rapport pardon excusez-moi par
rapport à ce que vous avez dit sur les
les développements de poste notamment et
leur contentement à ce sujet là et puis
peut-être revenir plus particulièrement
sur les priorités du gouvernement en
matière de contrôle sur le secteur
alimentaire c'est peut-être sur ça que
j'aimerais vous entendre sur ce sur plus
particulièrement merci
merci beaucoup Jean-Jacques Lasserre
pour le groupe udi bien merci Monsieur
le Ministre
autorisez-moi une obligation c'est bien
de nous apporter la démonstration que la
diminution de budget de l'agriculture
est compatible par tous les efforts qui
sont fait en matière de pacte de
responsabilité tout ça est vrai
si on rentre dans le détail le pacte de
responsabilité je crois ne touchera pas
tous les secteurs de crise ou ne pas de
corrélation avec les les grandes
interrogations qu'il y a sur le budget
de l'agriculture profiteront du pacte de
responsabilité bien sûr les industriels
je pense pour une très grande part et
heureusement heureusement parce qu'elles
en avaient bien besoin mais sur les
sujets que nous allons évoquer
ce pacte de responsabilité n'aura pas
n'aura pas d'influence alors je vais
aller très vite parce que les questions
ont été évoquées la limite de la limite
définie par l'Europe sur le
redéploiement des des aides des aides de
Pâques les ressources supplémentaires
pourraient
permettre de faire face aux besoins il
faut bien entendu que l'on sorte un peu
de cette situation qui est une situation
ambiguë j'ai une question à vous poser
monsieur le ministre sur les bâtiments
d'élevage le président de la République
est dans la loi qui a été votée c'était
un live motif il faut aider l'élevage il
faut est-ce que vous pouvez nous
indiquer qu'elle en sera je parle des
bâtiments d'élevage et de la mise au
norme qui est une grande préoccupation
dans le monde agricole au delà même du
monde céréalier moi je pense que les
lecteur animalier notamment dans les
régions traditionnelles risquent de
faire les frais de la crise parce que
les agriculteurs n'auront pas la
possibilité et de passer à la crise de
revenus et d'investir comme ils ont
l'obligation de le faire pouvez-vous
nous apporter les indications donc pour
ce qui est des bâtiments d'élevage et la
traduction dans ce budget je vais très
rapidement sur le les préoccupations
indiquées par les Chambres d'agriculture
c'est vrai quand même que depuis deux ou
trois années entre les prélèvements sur
le fond de roulement les avec une
assiette fiscale qui par définition ne
bouge pas ou plutôt a tendance à se
rétrécir le système des prélèvements
tout ceci plonge les Chambres
d'agriculture et puis on peut avoir tous
les jugements que l'on voudra c'est
quand même semi-publique qui sont censés
eux représenter la totalité de la
profession donc véritablement lorsque
nous en parlons et notamment avec les
responsables il y en a vraiment une
préoccupation c'est l'objet de mon c'est
l'objet de mon de ma question je passe
très très rapidement
pour rester sur le registre des chambres
elles ont tout de même elles ont elles
font des remplissent des fonctions qui
n'existaient pas notamment
l'accompagnement au niveau de
l'installation qui était qui faisait
l'objet de financement au départ
notamment de la disparition des anacéas
tout ceci a disparu je rejoins ce qui a
été dit sur la contribution des fonds
publics au niveau de l'assurance c'est
une grande ambition que d'essayer de
faire progresser le niveau le taux
d'assurance des agriculteurs face aux
calamités cette année nous aurons des
séquelles je crois des intempéries que
nous avons connues
est-ce que véritablement le
désengagement financier de que l'on voit
dans ce budget et avec la compensation
suggérer ou même si elle est effective
du budget européen nous peut nous mettre
en situation non seulement de
tranquillité mais d'offensive par
rapport justement à l'objectif qui est
de faire en sorte que beaucoup plus
d'agriculteurs s'assurent en ce moment
il a de véritables problèmes parce que
l'assurance est cher dans un monde en
crise et il faut absolument que la
puissance publique trouve les moyens de
garantir davantage de la profession
agricole
je pense que là vous allez engager assez
rapidement le redécoupage alors il y a
des dossiers ICA chaîne
primaire vous allez engager des
re-découpages sur les zones défavorisées
oui ou non bon
oui oui oui
et obtenu déjà sur ce sujet le fait que
la marge qui se proverbe de 10 % fasse
que les zones défavorisées françaises
actuelles soit couvertes avant
de passer on est les mêmes surfaces de
zone défavorisée après
le territoire s'interroge énormément sur
cette réforme là quelle sera la méthode
utilisée quelle sera la méthode utilisée
et quels seront les moyens de
consultation de prise de point de vue
notamment de la profession agricole et
des élus nous avons besoin parce qu'il y
a je vous assure il a véritablement de
l'inquiétude tout simplement parce que
les anciens sondages avaient été fait
allez dans des périodes de grande
facilité je n'irai pas jusqu'à dire
qu'ils n'ont pas toujours été objectif
par rapport à la réalité des citations
mais on n'est pas loin du compte et si
on va vers un système beaucoup plus
rigoureux beaucoup plus draconien il
peut y avoir des discussions qui
préoccupent en tout cas beaucoup les
agriculteurs dernière question je vais
j'en ai lu une quelques unes quand même
le compte de l'affectation spéciale je
parle du casdar la structure financière
la structure financière du Cazarre c'est
au bout du compte quasiment à
l'essentiel un prélèvement sur les
volumes produits
il est bien évident que tout échafaudage
d'affectation budgétaire est adossé sur
l'espérance que l'on a de volume de
production convenable très concrètement
en 2014 ça c'est plutôt bien passé en
2015 on a qu'une garantie et le Cazarre
finance des structures que nous
connaissons bien au cas de défaillance
d'intempéries de grands problèmes
qu'est-ce que vous avez est-ce que vous
avez des idées sur comment dirais-je la
prise en compte d'éventuelles donc
défaillances de ces de cette
paraffiscalité en quelque sorte un peu
la police
bien les contours et les fragilités bien
merci Jean Jacques avant de donner la
parole à Michel Sardin voudrait quand
même prolonger sur les champs
d'agriculture en disant il n'y a pas que
le prélèvement sur le fond de roulement
il y a la diminution de la taxe qui
permet à la Chambre d'Agriculture de
fonctionner or nous le savons la
diminution de la taxe va entraîner des
suppressions d'emplois les champs ne
peuvent pas faire autrement compte tenu
de de rétraction des moyens budgétaires
qui leur sont donnés Michel Le
squaredeck
parce que d'autres collègues veulent
poser des questions donc je pense à eux
je poserai deux questions dans l'une sur
l'adaptation des filières à l'évolution
des marchés c'est un poste qui perd 130
millions d'euros et la deuxième sur la
gestion équilibrée durable des
territoires qui perd également
6,84% donc les dotations mais comment
pour le premier donc adaptation des
filières à l'évolution des marchés
comment justifier une telle baisse aux
entreprises de transformation et de
commercialisation de produits agricoles
le soutien des entreprises à
l'internation et le soutient aussi des
filières en crise et je parle notamment
à la Bretagne vous êtes venu souvent
puisque il y a eu de multiples crises il
y a eu doux il y a eugad et Sabco et on
a fini pas
des centaines et des centaines entre
Finistère et Morbihan on a perdu
beaucoup de postes
et donc je sais que le ministre est venu
souvent en Bretagne il connaît bien la
question donc il y a mais donc comment
accepter de baisser les dotations sur le
secteur donc qui malheureusement n'est
pas réglé définitivement je pense que il
peut y avoir encore et là c'est des des
suites négatives concernant la gestion
équilibrée durable des territoires
persistent de 84% ça paraît beaucoup
d'autant que c'était décidé à favoriser
une agriculture compétitive et de
qualité des moyens qui sont affectés ont
pour but de favoriser l'attractivité des
territoires le maintien de la population
notamment à l'école et également
l'amélioration des pratiques agricoles
respectueuses de l'environnement donc
alors je me je pense donc au petit
producteurs et en même temps je vais
poser la question les grands élevages
enfin moi je suis fils de paysans je
comprends mal un peu les les élevages à
millevages et les milliers de truies
donc moi je préfère défendre endre
oui mais même bon défendre la petite
agriculture
qui concerne beaucoup plus d'emplois qui
concerne bien sur le maillage du
territoire et l'emploi dans nos zones
rurales donc je voudrais bien qu'on
avance un peu dans le bon sens en ce qui
concerne cette évolution merci bien
merci alors monsieur le ministre vous
êtes la parole merci monsieur le
Président bon il y a eu plusieurs
questions il y a souvent il y a deux
grandes questions structurantes dans les
débats qu'on aura il y a le contrat
vendanges et la question des chambres
d'agriculture on est d'accord donc je
vais essayer d'abord de répondre aux
autres questions puis je finirai sur ces
deux sujets qui sont et l'assurance
récolte d'accord et sur l'assurance
école
sur la question du modèle de la
modernisation
sur les bâtiments d'élevage on est sur
un plan de modernisation qui a mobilisé
200 millions d'euros c'est-à-dire avec
un prélèvement de 2% sous le premier
pilier 200 millions d'euros qui sont
complétés avec je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure les 56 millions d'euros de
l'État c'est ça le plan 200 millions
d'euros total + 56 millions de la part
de l'État dans l'application de la
modernisation les régions qui sont
aujourd'hui
autorité de paix de gestion on fait des
choix elles ont fixé des priorités moi
j'avais fixé il y avait quatre grandes
priorités dans la modernisation il y
avait le bien-être animal l'efficacité
énergétique des bâtiments pour le lait
il y avait des grandes questions posées
par des salles de traite et puis il y
avait les questions globales de
l'installation donc chaque région
structure et je suis d'ailleurs
extrêmement
agréablement surpris de la manière dont
ça travaille avec des priorités une de
trois quatre qui sont négociées je le
dis avec la profession quel est le
niveau exact qui sera consacré à la
modernisation des bâtiments d'élevage ça
va dépendre des régions n'a pas encore
le retour définitif mais on pourra vous
donner des éléments sur ce sujet sachant
que l'enveloppe globale c'est 200
millions d'accord mais selon les régions
si je prends les régions d'élevage
traditionnelles on va plutôt vers la
modernisation des bâtiments d'élevage en
particulier viande bovine si je prends
la Bretagne il y a sûrement j'ai pas
regardé mais une partie qui doit être
consacrée au lait et au cochon en même
temps bon sur le mise en mise au normes
le bien-être et tout ça bon donc c'est
il faut qu'on fasse une une analyse
puisque maintenant les choses qui ont
été négociées avec la profession
agricole comment ça remonter c'est ça
qui se passe avec à chaque fois quand on
a une enveloppe toujours des priorités
qui peuvent être contestées j'ai
rencontré
il y a pas très longtemps
quelqu'un qui me disait que il
regrettait que la priorité c'était la
FNPL que dans les Pays de Loire
la mise la modernisation des salles de
traite viennent qu'en 4 alors qu'en 1
c'était l'installation en deux c'était
je sais plus quoi en 3 c'était autre
chose mais là ils me disait en même
temps c'est vrai que le choix était fait
aussi par la profession avec la région
bon mais on est très soucieux de cette
question de modernisation des bâtiments
d'élevage donc on fera le point sur
Midi-Pyrénées
pour que les choses vous soient données
mais c'est comme ça que c'est structuré
sur la question posée sur les 1000
vaches les 520 chez les minicornes
puisqu'il y a deux cornes vaches si quoi
oui on les coupe mais enfin quand même
quel est l'enjeu d'abord c'est un projet
il est symbolique il a fait l'objet de
beaucoup de
discussions mais ça n'a jamais été le
projet du ministre ni du gouvernement
puisque oui mais il faut bien rappeler
ça dans la réforme de la Politique
agricole commune pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de la distribution des
aides de la dégressivité dans les aides
avec ce qu'on appelle le paiement
redistributif pour les 52 premiers
hectares la Bretagne jaune d'élevage de
polyculture élevage ou les gaecs
reconnus maintenant à l'échelle
européenne
vont pouvoir bénéficier de la
transparence des aides vieux sujet en
permettant d'ailleurs à des EURL de
revenir en système GAEC pour justement
bénéficier de la transparence des aides
c'est quoi l'objectif
c'est de donner des dimensions
économiques collectives
avec des chefs d'exploitation qui
restent des agriculteurs
c'est ça l'enjeu tout a été fait pour ça
c'est le contraire de ce qui est proposé
avec des millemins ou un investisseur
regroupe 6 exploitations et dit je mets
500 vaches sur 6 exploitations c'est
bien le contraire donc il faut pas se
laisser
emmener sur ce terrain-là le projet et
de la politique agricole commune
négociée et de la loi d'avenir et des
outils qu'on a mis en place c'est tout
le contraire c'est de garder les
agriculteurs et des chefs d'exploitation
de bain même si en les regroupant on
leur donne des tailles économiques qui
permettent aussi d'assurer leur
compétitivité je vais ça parce que sinon
le risque c'est que on se fasse
rattraper doubler et puis qu'après on a
sur même pas notre production donc c'est
ça qu'on a fait et c'est pourquoi je
l'ai déjà dit sur ces questions de débat
sur les paiements redistributifs sur ah
les gars sur la compensation d'handicap
parce que la compensation handicap avec
les grands galettes dans des zones
herbagères et de handicap c'est bien ça
le sujet aussi c'est d'aller dans ce
sens là moi je veux garder les
agriculteurs
c'est pas encore le débat uniquement sur
le nombre de vaches
même s'il peut mais c'est que derrière
il y ait des agriculteurs et qu'on soit
surtout attentif aux grandes questions
posées par des troupeaux et des
investissements extrêmement importants
qui finissent par poser des problèmes
sanitaires des problèmes envers donc là
tout le projet qu'on a c'est tout le
contraire c'était pour répondre à votre
question pour bien dire que même si ça
existe c'est comme je le dis sur le
barrage sur la question du barrage de
Sivas il est plus question de faire des
retenues ou des barrages pour faire de
l'irrigation pour faire du maïs irrigué
d'abord parce que l'histoire du maïs est
Riguet elle est pas liée à des retenues
colinaires elle est liée à au nappe
phréatique c'est toutes les grandes
zones de maïs irriguées les Landes
l'Alsace c'était d'abord même même ce
qui s'est passé en Poitou-Charentes avec
avec le marais poitevin tout le débat
sur le maïs irrigué c'était parce que
c'était des zones extrêmement humide et
c'était de la du prélèvement et
d'irrigation sur de la de l'eau
superficielle donc la stratégie c'est
pas du tout celle-là je l'ai dit
dimanche dans une émission la stratégie
de notre stratégie elle est claire c'est
que toutes ces retenues doivent servir
d'abord à permettre d'assurer le
maintien de l'élevage dans des zones où
une sécheresse de printemps a des
résultats catastrophiques sur la
production fourragère si c'est tout et
on en a pas vu de grosses sécheresses de
printemps mais on sait ce que ça donne
nous hein tous on a tous des régions où
quand ça sèche ça sèche et il y a pas
que le maïs qui est touché il y a
l'herbe aussi
bon donc il faut qu'on soit là dessus
sur cette ligne là en tout cas le
ministère de l'Agriculture je le dis ici
devant la commission c'est sa stratégie
les retenues d'eau sont faites pour
assurer une production minimale de
protéines fourragères pour maintenir
l'élevage là où il y a des risques de
sécheresse c'est ça l'objectif bon
alors il y a les deux les questions
liées aux champs de l'agriculture alors
les champs de l'agriculture sont des
établissements publics sur et tout le
monde fait des efforts de réduction de
la dépense publique on a un budget il y
avait des recettes pour les champs
d'agriculture les champs d'agriculture
c'est le constat qu'on a fait avait des
fonds de roulement qui dépassaient la
règle prudentielle des deux mois
alors c'est lié à une bonne gestion je
remets pas ça en cause mais une chambre
d'agriculture n'a pas vocation à faire
et à accumuler du fonds de roulement
et comme on est dans une période de
restriction budgétaire c'est vrai qu'on
va aller prélever prélever une part du
fond de roulement pour limiter la
dépense publique
mais on garde les deux mois de règles
prudentielles ça vaut aussi pour le CNPF
c'est la même chose
c'est trois mois
trois mois pour les chambres deux mois
pour le CNPF donc il y a aucun problème
en terme de gestion les règles
prudentielles sont respectées
deuxièmement j'ai veillé aussi et ça ça
a été l'objet d'une discussion qui est
remontée par les préfets à ce que les
chambres qui avaient prévu des
investissements
ne soient pas remis en cours que ces
investissements ne soient pas remis en
cause lorsqu'ils avaient été prévus dans
les budgets de pour 2015 précédent donc
jusque 2014
tous les projets d'investissement qui
avaient été décidé avant le 1er juillet
2014 sont intégrés
pourquoi parce que après c'est le 1er
août et les discussions dans mes madame
assezatrice et discussions budgétaires
s'arrêtent à un moment donc pour le
budget de 2015 on a choisi la date du
premier juillet 2014 si écoutez si le
fait d'annoncer qu'on va prendre sous le
fond de roulement suscite des
investissements on a changé la règle
mais oui c'est moi qui l'a change je
l'assume mais je ne peux pas laisser
penser que parce que les chambres
anticipaient le fait qu'on prenne du
fond de roulement elles se mettent à
faire des investissements qu'elle
n'avait pas prévu et c'est pourquoi je
reste sur la ligne qui est la mienne au
1er juillet si si si si si si non non
messieurs les sénateurs soyez soyons
honnêtes entre nous
les chambres qui n'avaient pas prévu
d'investissement
avant le premier juillet 2014
soyons allons jusqu'au bout ça veut dire
que il aurait fallu attendre jusqu'à
maintenant pour décider des
investissements parce que justement ça a
évité qui est une ponction sur le
changement
là c'était une incitation peut-être
d'ailleurs qui aurait pu être utile à
l'investissement mais moi j'ai regardé
ce qui avait été prévu et ce que j'ai
voulu c'est respecter les
investissements qui avaient été prévus
et donc jusqu'au 1er juillet tous les
investissements sont pris en compte
ça c'est le respect de la gestion des
chambres
mais on peut pas aller jusqu'à la fin de
l'année sinon je crée des
investissements ne rien que pour ne pas
utiliser le fond de roulement
c'est de la très bonne gestion et le
fondrement reste de trois mois donc le
prélèvement
le prélèvement total si j'avais écouté
si j'avais écouté les je rappelle aussi
d'ailleurs que les chambres ont été
préservées jusqu'ici
alors que d'autres ont été touchés bien
avant les chambres de l'agriculture et
si je l'ai fait et si j'ai préservé on
devrait déjà tenir crédit de ça parce
que vous avez qu'à regarder ce qui se
passe avec les chambres de métier et
vous avez qu'à regarder ce qui se passe
avec les chances de commerce l'effort
qui est demandé il y a encore bien plus
important moi j'ai voulu préserver le
rôle la place des chambres et des
investissements donc le prélèvement il
aurait pu selon les propositions que
j'avais pu avoir d'ailleurs de 135
millions d'euros on a choisi de rester à
90 millions d'euros
sur trois ans
ensuite on a un prélèvement sur le fond
de roulement
et une partie de ce prélèvement va
servir aussi à baisser un baisser ce
qu'on appelle une des taxes qui pèse sur
qui pèse sur les propriétaires c'est la
taxe foncier non-batique parce que une
partie et ça ça a été de la discussion
avec Bercy ce que je ne voulais pas
c'est que l'effort qui soit demandé aux
chambres partent dans le budget de
manière générale mais que l'effort qui
est demandé aux chambres reste dans le
domaine de l'agriculture donc une partie
ira pour baisser les taxes sur le fond
innovati une autre nous permettra de
financer un fonds de péréquation de 25
millions d'euros qui viendra justement
assurer la solidarité parce que selon
les cas je suis obligé de le constater
aussi vous avez des chambres et vous le
savez qui sont bien plus comment
dirais-je en situation favorable au
niveau financier et je leur reproche pas
que d'autres qui sont beaucoup plus en
situation beaucoup plus fragile dans les
zones on peut en particulier ou
l'activité AG ricole connaît plus de
difficultés donc le fond de péréquation
de 25 millions et là pour répondre à la
nécessaire solidarité qui doit y avoir
entre les champs d'agriculture je
rajoute d'ailleurs que grâce à ce fond
de péréquation
on a renforcé le rôle et la place de la
PCA
parce que moi j'ai aussi en tête que les
champs de l'agriculture c'est pas elles
sont pas départementales d'ailleurs
elles se régionalise de plus en plus
c'est l'objectif et deuxièmement le rôle
de la PCA de cet assemblée générale des
gens doit être renforcée et le front de
prééquation est un élément de cette
capacité politique donner à la PCA de
pouvoir aussi piloter à la fois
l'ensemble des champs et de pouvoir
assurer la solidarité pour celle qui ont
des difficultés ou qui sont plus
fragiles c'est ça le sujet et l'effort
qui sera demandé en termes structurel
au-delà de prélèvement sur le fonds de
roulement il est exactement de 45
millions d'euros c'est-à-dire 15
millions de tous les ans c'est à dire 5%
par an pas plus
c'est beaucoup je suis d'accord c'est
beaucoup mais c'est pas plus l'état fait
bien plus
l'état fait bien plus
oui vous avez dit vous-même vous avez
les premiers à dire que les efforts
qu'on fait sur les crédits de paiement
on fait beaucoup d'efforts vous l'avez
dit donc l'état fait des efforts les
champs de la rupture doit faire des
efforts je vais pas rappeler ce que font
comme effort les chambres de commerce ou
les chambres de métiers
tout le monde doit faire des efforts on
a tous une responsabilité et les
établissements publics quels qu'ils
soient doivent faire des efforts c'est
bien le sujet et dans cet effort je le
rappelle quand on va prélever le fond de
roulement on le prélève tout en gardant
les règles prudentielles on n'a pas on
ne remet rien en cause là-dessus
mais avouez quand même que si il y a un
fondement qui est conséquent et c'est
lié à des bonnes gestion mais ça veut
dire aussi que ce qui était la dépense
budgétaire de l'État tous les ans
elle était utilisée à faire un fond de
roulement ce qui est quand même pas
l'objectif quand on a un problème
budgétaire on est obligé de le gérer
mais oui
tout le monde est d'accord et en
particulier vous allez proposer des
économies et un budget alternatif tout
le monde est d'accord pour faire des
économies et tout le monde le dit ben il
faut que chacun soit mis devant ses
responsabilités lorsqu'il faut en faire
des économies et on le fait avec le
souci de maintenir le rôle la place des
chambres d'agriculture sur
les questions liées
oui alors
le contrat vendanges
parce que ça c'est le deuxième sujet qui
intéresse et en particulier Gérard tout
le monde alors le contrat vendange
c'était une exception
lié au vendanges et au fait que pour
vendanger on avait recours à une main
d'oeuvre étudiante salariés retraités
tout ça
il n'est pas remis en cause
qui c'est qui a dit ça
le contrat vendange continue d'exister
et il permet de cumuler des retraites
des tout ça ne bouge pas qu'est-ce qui
est supprimé
ah ce qui est supprimé c'est
l'exonération de cotisations salariale
pour les salariés pour les salariés
pour les salariés c'est à dire le fait
que l'État prenait en charge une partie
de la cotisation payée par les salariés
c'est ça
j'indique d'abord par rapport à ce qui a
été dit par Gérard que sur la question
du
coût du travail pour les
les viticulteurs
la viticulture va bénéficier c'est ce
que j'ai dit des dans les 730 millions
de 60 millions d'euros supplémentaires
d'abaissement du coût du travail ce qui
fera qu'en termes de de d'abaissement
général on est à 344 millions pour 2015
d'aide et d'allègement de charge pour la
viticulture donc si c'est la question
des viticulteurs
il bénéficie de 60 millions de plus par
rapport à cette année
ça c'est pour les entreprises alors
après c'est la question des salariés
sous-entendu le fait qu'on ait pu
l'exonération de cotisation des salariés
va faire que les gens vont moins venir
faire des vents chez ça que vous dites
pour à peine 8% de la totalité du coup
salariale ça fait quand même beaucoup je
rappelle d'ailleurs je rappelle
d'ailleurs que aujourd'hui on a passé la
barre des plus de 50% de l'utilisation
du recours à la directive des
travailleurs détachés dans les vendanges
avec le contrat vendange qui existe
pourtant donc l'idée que cette mesure
viendrait accélérer ou viendrait
favoriser le recours à des travailleurs
détachés je suis désolé c'est pas c'est
pas ce que je souhaite mais c'est déjà
le cas à plus de 50%. deuxièmement je
vais vous le dire là aussi c'est que si
cette mesure on l'a prise c'est parce
que il y a eu un recours qui a été
déposé aux conséquences institutionnels
qui a été signé par un certain nombre de
députés VP dont certains sont dans des
zones viticoles je prends en particulier
monsieur Bussereau qui a été un très bon
ministre de l'Agriculture
mais qui a signé ce recours et qu'est-ce
que disait ce recours signé par l'UMP il
disait qu'il y avait pourquoi il y avait
une justification de ce recours je vais
vous le dire parce que c'est les
collègues de l'Assemblée qui l'ont écrit
voilà
c'est que ça crée davantage encore le
législateur par la mesure qui était
prévue par le gouvernement c'est-à-dire
un allègement des cotisations payées par
les salariés jusqu'à 1,3 SMIC c'était ça
qui était proposé dans la première
proposition
ça correspondait exactement à ce qui
existe sous le contrat vendeur
aujourd'hui donc le recours qui a été
déposé par les collègues de l'UMP a été
posée en partie avec cet argument le
législateur crée une rupture d'égalité
devant la loi puisque c'est salarié
continueront de jouir d'un niveau de
prestation sociale inchangé sans
supporter aucune charge inhérente à ce
mécanisme solidarité donc je le dis à
partir du moment où on pose ce recours
et que le Conseil constitutionnel donne
raison
au à ceux qui ont fait ce recours et
bien la règle s'applique aussi aux
contrat vendanges qui existaient et qui
était exactement le même principe qu'on
avait proposé mais contre lequel vos
collègues de l'UMP ils ont saisi le
Conseil constitutionnel donc à partir du
moment où juridiquement
et bien on a été condamné sur cette
exonération de cotisation salariale bien
ça s'applique aussi malheureusement au
contrat vendanges
et les salariés du contrat vendanges
bénéficieront comme tous les salariés
puisque c'est ce qui est la mesure qui a
été décidé qui est en discussion et qui
sera décidé ici aussi au Sénat c'est la
mesure de la suppression de la première
tranche de l'impôt qui va se substituer
à cette mesure d'exonération de
cotisations sociales pour les salariés
voilà donc sous le contrat vendanges
franchement un pour les employeurs les
viticulteurs ça ne change rien au
contraire ils vont encore bénéficier de
60 millions d'euros d'allégeant de
charge supplémentaires ça ne concerne
que les salariés que les salariés qui
avaient une exonération de cotisations
sociales mesure qui était proposée pour
être appliqué à tous les autres salariés
qui ne peut plus l'être à cause du
recours qui a été posé sur le conseil au
Conseil constitutionnel donc voilà on
est dans ce sujet là tout simplement
mais le contre-end je reste
cadre juridique reste la seule chose qui
change c'est la partie des cotisations
sociales salariale j'aurais rajouté
juste un tout petit mot pour vous donner
à peu près la répartition de ce contrat
qui en bénéficie plus ça va rassurer un
certain nombre de sénateurs et
certainement de régions peut-être
inquiéter en particulier un peu plus
Gérard mais enfin bon
aujourd'hui si je regarde
oui mais la mécanisation Gérard elle ne
peut pas être liée uniquement à la
suppression de la cotisation sociale sur
les salariés quand même ça c'est pas
vrai c'est pas possible voilà sinon ça
veut dire alors sur les 17 millions
d'euros que coûté le contrat vengeance
versus exonération de cotisation sociale
salarié les chiffres que nous avons
montrent que vous les donnera d'ailleurs
qu'il y a des endroits qui en
bénéficient beaucoup plus si je prends
un département qui viticole important
comme la Marne par exemple c'est près de
24 à 28% de la totalité des sommes si je
prends et ça c'est pour Gérard la
Gironde elle doit bénéficier de 12% mais
sinon mais je conteste pas c'est quoi je
ne conteste pas monsieur le sénateur
mais je dis simplement que dans des
endroits où la question posée c'est
celle des salariés là où il y a une
viticulture qui tient la route
qui a et c'est tant mieux pour la France
tant mieux pour la France
et l'export
il y a des moyens pour ajuster ce qui
est la perte de cette exonération de
cotisation
salariale par les employeurs qui
bénéficient en même temps je le rappelle
des 60 millions d'exonérations qui vont
venir sur le travail lié au pack de
responsabilité voilà le sujet il est là
c'est pour ça que je dis que le contrat
reste la seule chose qui change c'est
exode cotisation sociale salariale mais
que là elle est largement compensée par
la baisse liée au pacte de
responsabilité
et puis sur les priorités sur le
sanitaire Frédéric lesagnac là la
priorité c'est justement de créer 60
portes sur les contrôles dans les
abattoirs parce que ça a été noté et par
la Cour des comptes et au niveau
européen il faut qu'on s'assure des
conditions sanitaires dans les abattoirs
parce que c'est la condition aussi de
pouvoir exporter ensuite de la viande en
Europe et ailleurs et donc là les 60
postes c'est pour renforcer ces
contrôles voilà c'est assez simple mais
c'est ça l'objectif
à l'assurance récolte c'est très
important ça c'est un sujet c'est
oui oui c'est Gérard et puis voilà où on
en est d'abord moi j'ai monté le
financement de
à 100 millions d'euros c'est à dire on
est passé de 85 millions à 100 millions
d'euros pour ce qui est de l'État
ensuite
qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse c'est
qu'on trouve ce fameux système sur
lequel travaille d'ailleurs
la viticulteurs et en particulier dans
dans la région Aquitaine il faut qu'on
arrive à mettre en place des dispositifs
et des outils et des mesures qui sont
des mesures assurantielles mutualisées
c'est ça l'enjeu l'État doit venir avec
des fonds publics mais après il faut
qu'on mobilise aussi l'ensemble des
fonds liés aux assureurs potentiels
qu'est-ce qui se passe on va reporter la
mise en oeuvre de tout le dispositif au
début de l'été 2015 parce qu'on devait
le faire d'ici la fin de l'année mais
comme ces discussions c'est à la fois la
mobilisation je l'ai dit d'assureur qui
sont pas forcément tous dans des
situations faciles aujourd'hui c'est
aussi un système de réassurance qu'il
faut organiser public et privé ça ça a
bien avancé
ce que je sais maintenant
c'est qualité on aura des établissements
financiers qui viendront
répondre à la demande
puisque dans les débats qui ont lieu je
prends par exemple sur le lait la
difficulté c'était de mobiliser alors on
va se parler franchement entre Crédit
Agricole et Groupama c'était Groupama
qui aujourd'hui assume pas 80% de la
mutualisation des assurances avait des
difficultés à aller plus loin le Crédit
Agricole comme Groupama ça y est ce sont
mis d'accord donc par exemple sur la
question laitière le système va être
commence à être mis en oeuvre on va
signer un pacte avec la FNPL d'ici la
fin d'année et il y aura dedans cette
partie assurancielle sur la viticulture
pareil on sait maintenant que même
d'autres opérateurs financiers sont
prêts à venir donc on est plus dans on
est plus dans l'impossibilité de mettre
en oeuvre ensuite à terme je l'ai déjà
dit dans des discussions mais là
j'anticipe pas sur la suite mais les 100
millions d'euros qu'on a aujourd'hui
public ou les prélèvements sur le
premier pilier par exemple pour le plan
de modernisation qu'on est en train de
mettre en oeuvre sur bâtiment bâtiment
d'élevage un jour
d'ici trois quatre ans la question qui
sera posée c'est combien nous prenons
sur le premier pilier pour mettre en
soutien au système assurantiel parce que
c'est vrai que les aléas climatiques
comme ça tombe d'aller à économiques
c'est le gros enjeu de des années à
venir pour la vie culture mais ça ça
sera une décision je l'ai déjà dit les
professionnels
les syndicats sont tout à fait
conscients de ça c'est-à-dire qu'une
fois qu'on aura engagé la modernisation
qu'on aura financé la modernisation sur
le les bâtiments d'élevage il y aura une
question à se poser est-ce qu'on met
toujours 200 millions sur la
modernisation ou est-ce qu'on en prend
une part pour abonder et soutenir le
système assurantiel et ça c'est une
question politique qui est posée
aujourd'hui mais qui se traduira
concrètement dans trois quatre ans on
est bien d'accord moi là-dessus ce que
je vais faire ministre de l'Agriculture
c'est qu'il y aura de mise sur la table
le système
il sera fait début d'année avant l'été
2015 normalement on aura un système en
place avec ce qu'on appelle oui c'est
vrai le fameux contrat socle
c'est-à-dire que chaque agriculteur aura
un contrat de base qui lui permettra
d'être assuré contre les aléas c'est ça
l'enjeu donc ça ça sera fait puis après
comme on le finance bah il y aura les
cotisations mais il y aura aussi est-ce
que c'est pas intelligent de prendre ou
prélever une partie des 7 milliards du
premier pilier pour en mettre alors
après à quel niveau ça sera la
discussion qui sera ouverte mais ça elle
aura lieu plus tard pour le mettre sur
le système assurance en tout cas c'est
ça l'objectif mettre en place ce système
et puis après la montée
comme vous le disiez monsieur mini je
crois que c'est très intelligent
je pense moi
on va ici ici et Norvège je pense que si
ça permet de mettre à l'abri tout
producteur par rapport à des aléas
climatiques météorologiques etc dès lors
que c'est obligatoire je pense que ce
serait intéressant alors nous allons
prendre les demandes d'intervention je
les prends dans l'ordre où elles se sont
manifestées donc d'abord Gérard Bailly
ensuite Roland Courtot merci un
président monsieur le ministre
comme vous le savez quand même les
agriculteurs étaient dans la rue à la
semaine dernière dans nombreux
départements quand même aujourd'hui je
sais bien vos convictions pour défendre
l'agriculture mais malgré tout quand
même on s'aperçoit c'est vrai que c'est
pas toujours d'autres fait loin sans
faut pour desserrer à la baisse
l'élevage aujourd'hui demandait un
agriculteur combien elle vend un petit
veau vous voyez aussi combien le prix du
lait aux industriels et quand même
enrichissement donc aujourd'hui il y a
un vrai problème quand même de
rentabilité du mode agricole et on peut
comprendre cela alors d'abord ma
question la première c'est sur
l'inquiétude par rapport à toujours
assez de course au prix bas qui sont
faits par les grandes surfaces et le
dernier accord si c'était mieux aux
champs au casino Intermarché est-ce que
vous pensez pas qu'il y aura encore des
conséquences plus fortes vers un
retourne au transformateur qui
finalement la peur du déférencement
quand aujourd'hui ces groupes avec leur
association vont faire 20 à 25% de part
de marché et combien de transformateurs
ne peuvent pas accepter et bien de
perdre cela et puis on le sent déjà
depuis des années où les transformateurs
enfin tous nos notre PME de
l'agroalimentaire ben pèsent sur les
prix à la production donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un vrai problème
mais je crois que c'est celui-là qui est
capital c'est comment mettre frein quand
même au toujours à la course au prix bas
qui est en train qui va diminuer le
nombre de producteurs demain puis
diminuer de beaucoup parce que je crois
qu'on a déjà perdu 44 000 emplois ces 10
dernières années dans la transformation
agroalimentaire donc c'est la première
ma première question la deuxième c'est
aussi les inquiétudes par rapport à tout
ce qui est les zones verdissement j'ai
pas le temps d'allonger mais vous le
savez aussi que cela est important vous
dites on peut aussi faire des économies
c'est une ministre c'est tout ce qu'on
donne pour les prédateurs vous savez que
c'est quelque chose de fort encore un
éleveur de moutons avec un rendez-vous
je crois que c'est aujourd'hui ou demain
avec le préfet dit j'en ai marre quand
même 132 moutons qui sont fait
dévorés de quinté par les Lynx ces
dernières années alors moi je crois
qu'on a quand même beaucoup d'argent
aussi que jamais vouloir supprimer un
loup en link parce que les loups on a
prévoit dans dans supprimer 40 mais
finalement on en tue 11 quand même que
sur les prédateurs il faudra bien aussi
qu'on arrête de décourager un certain
nombre d'éleveurs bon ces zones là sur
ce secteur là autre inquiétude aussi est
plus responsable de tout ce qui est
animal c'est aujourd'hui ce qui est
évoqué par rapport si c'est vrai que les
animaux ne sont pas des tables des
meubles aujourd'hui est-ce que quand
même on a un petit peu peur que ces
mouvements et un petit peu trop loin par
des intégristes par rapport au statut de
l'animal et et aujourd'hui quand je vois
encore des articles on lui comme on lit
qui invite les gens contre
l'alimentation carnet etc donc les
éleveurs peuvent quand même se poser des
inquiétudes pour demain c'était les
principes et d'autres questions mais
c'était les principales questions que je
voulais poser surtout tout ce qui est
aujourd'hui problème des prix problèmes
des grandes surfaces qui nous étrangle
tous et le statut de l'animal qui sont
des vrais inquiétudes à mon avis c'est
pas des crédits budgétaires de ce
ministère mais c'est des vrais problèmes
de fond à se poser pour les années à
venir et j'aimerais qu'on y travaille en
profondeur merci à Gérard Bailly donc
maintenant
vous répondrai parce que mon train va
pas attendre mais je verrai le compte
rendu bien
Roland Courtot et ensuite Daniel Dubois
oui merci monsieur le Président moi je
me réjouis c'est le premier des
enneigement du coup du travail et des
effets du pacte de responsabilité qui
représente vous l'avez rappelé
730 millions de plus donc de soutien à
ce secteur deux j'apprécie que les aides
à la conversion et au maintien de
l'agriculture biologique ainsi que les
mesures agro-amémentales et climatiques
enregistrent une hausse importante ce
sont des secteurs que je suis avec
beaucoup d'intérêt 3 je vous félicite
pour vos actions concernant notamment la
gestion des conséquences de l'embargo
russe cela dit 4 c'était le contrat
vendanges alors j'allais dire on en
reparlera à la lumière des arguments que
vous avez évoqués qui mérite qui mérite
réflexion simplement je ne suis pas
certain que tous les viticulteurs
puissent bénéficier du cice et notamment
ceux qui sont imposés au bénéfice
forfaitaire autre question rapide je
passe une assurance face aux aléas
climatiques par contre la retraite des
exploitants agricoles
la moyenne des pensions se situe autour
de 680 euros alors qu'il y a déjà eu
quelques revalorisations je rappelle que
le seuil de pauvreté se situe autour de
monsieur le ministre de la
revalorisation des retraites les plus
faibles et de l'objectif de 75 %
du SMIC concernant la réforme du forfait
agricole et là il y a de fortes
inquiétudes notamment dans les secteurs
viticoles de mon département en effet la
majorité des exploitations est au
forfait agricole en raison des faibles
revenus dégagées pouvez-vous là-dessus
m'apporter tous apaisement sur ce
dossier et puis le dernier point
concerne les maladies de la vigne et
notamment l'Escat c'est devenu un énorme
problème depuis que on ne peut plus
traiter avec je crois l'arsenic de
sodium qui est un produit
particulièrement
particulièrement la jauge je le
reconnais mais où en est-on là aussi de
la recherche et de l'application de
nouveaux produits merci bien merci à
Roland Courtot avant de donner la parole
à Daniel Dubois je pense qu'elle est
membre de la commission seront heureux
d'apprendre que le robot filae a réussi
à se poser sur la commettre Zeta nous
pouvons effectivement
collectivement applaudir ce grand succès
scientifique et technologique européen
bien
Daniel Dubois et ensuite daniel
grimillier Merci monsieur le Président
tout d'abord monsieur le Président moi
je voulais faire une observation à mon
collègue breton pour lui dire que je
suis aussi fils d'agriculteurs que j'ai
fait des études agricoles au parapluie
entre d'autres fréquentés je dirais
voilà donc
et je voulais simplement lui dire que la
ferme des 520ches et non pas des
millevages nous enverrons très
certainement de plus en plus si nous
voulons continuer à produire du lait
dans notre pays concurrentiel avec la
production allemande et de bien d'autres
pays et du Danemark voilà donc ceci
étant dit bien entendu tous les enquêtes
publiques ont été menées à leur terme
les signatures d'ouverture ont été
obtenus
et donc c'est une réalité moi je suis
même parfois surpris du double langage
parce qu'à un moment donné soit on
respecte les règles légales et
l'ouverture est entérinée par une
signature du préfet et dans ce cas là et
bien finalement tout le monde tient le
même langage ou alors finalement le
préfet n'est pas le représentant de
l'État sans son territoire voilà ça
c'est une question que je me pose à un
moment donné où les entrepreneurs ont
besoin de confiance et donc j'aurais de
certitudes et la règle précise et
appliquée pour tous de la même façon
voilà ceci étant dit je rejoins mon
collègue Gérard Bailly et mes questions
sont assez pratiquées pratiques monsieur
le ministre face à la concentration des
centrales d'achat est-ce que
l'Observatoire des prix et les marges
est encore efficace ou est-ce que c'est
devenu un hochet et est-ce qu'il faut
pas adapter les règles
phase finalement aujourd'hui
à cette puissance
face aux agriculteurs même s'ils sont
organisés en filière aujourd'hui je
pense qu'ils ne font pas le poids même
s'il y a un médiateur il faut
certainement réfléchir à une autre façon
d'appréhender la relation vendeur
acheteur à être dans ce domaine faute de
quoi je pense que nous serons toujours
confrontés à cette problématique
finalement du pot de terre contre le pot
de fer première élément
réglementation sur les nitrates de
deuxième deuxième question donc son
nouvelle contrainte naturellement qui
vont être infligées alors moi je
voudrais monsieur le ministre que vous
viviez nous expliquer quelles sont les
critères qui vont être pris en compte
pour ces extensions est-ce que sont des
critères statistiques ou scientifiques
parce qu'il y a de grands débats dans
mon département il y a déjà eu une
extension une fois avec un avis négatif
des services de l'État dans le
département de la Somme qui n'a pas été
suivi par le préfet qui était en charge
de l'extension qui était le préfet de
région de la région Nord-Pas-de-Calais
donc quels sont les critères et que les
choses soient claires parce que à un
moment donné finalement il y aurait il y
a eu deux langages de l'administration
et il n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui il y a un
recours au tribunal mais il n'empêche
que l'extension a été faite donc ça
c'est ma deuxième question ensuite la la
réglementation des périodes d'épandage
c'est très technique finalement mes
questions sauf qu'on les raccourcis ça
veut donc dire qu'on va avoir des
surcoutes de fonctionnement et surtout
on va devoir modifier les zones de
stockage et donc comment gérer tout cela
s'organise de façon pratique ou pratique
pour les agriculteurs je ne reviens pas
sur les Chambres d'agriculture en ce qui
concerne le verdissement monsieur le
ministre finalement les contraintes sont
pas encore clairement précisé les normes
et ceci étant dit gérer les agriculteurs
ont déjà les résumé ils ont déjà ils ont
déjà fait les leurs enveloppements alors
comment ça se règle si ça ne se règle
pas de façon précise en amont on va
encore se trouver avec des agriculteurs
qui a juste titre vont dire mais
finalement vous nous faites des
contrôles mais on connaissait pas les
règles donc comment voulez-vous qu'on
les applique donc c'est un peu pratique
au pratique
bien merci Daniel Dubois Daniel
grémillier et enfin bruno Sido
oui merci président monsieur le ministre
tout d'abord je voudrais vous encourager
dans la démarche que vous avez
entreprises avec 22 autres pays sur
effectivement la gestion des faux
communautaires au niveau de la gestion
de crise
et je serai tenté de dire
il faut qu'on vous soutienne
complètement quand on sait comment la
situation agricole est en train de se
dégrader au niveau européen au niveau
des marchés et que même si vous arrivez
à sauver ce qui existe dans le cadre de
la nouvelle réforme de la PAC je crains
que les situations vécues par
différentes régions agricoles de
l'Europe soit
largement supérieur en termes de besoins
sur par rapport au moyen qui sont
aujourd'hui identifiés donc je souhaite
vraiment être conscient à vos côtés sur
cette initiative parce qu'elle sera au
combien importante pour 2015
sur le cice pourrait être très très
rapide c'est très bien sauf qu'il y a
une partie des entreprises dans notre
pays qui n'ont pas accès ce sont les
coopératives donc on est dans une
situation effectivement
c'est quand même surprenant d'avoir la
grande distribution premier bénéficiaire
du cice et d'avoir les entreprises de
coopératives de paysans qui vendent sur
le marché ne pas pouvoir en bénéficier
sur l'accord de la grande distribution
aujourd'hui rejoins ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure mais je serai quand même
une remarque c'est quand même surprenant
qu'on autorise dans notre pays de tel
accord alors qu'il n'y a aucun accord
juridique et que si deux entreprises
françaises discutent entre elles sur la
mise en marché de leurs produits se font
attraper par les lois de la concurrence
et se font condamner il y a quand même
là aussi et on n'est pas dans des
proportions identiques sur les moyens
mis en marché donc il y a vraiment un
gros problème
je rejoins ce qui a été dit sur la
directive nitrate et je voudrais aller
plus loin vous avez annoncé
l'objectif d'avoir 50% des exploitations
qui ont basculé dans l'agroécologie
horizon 2025
c'est un objectif qui peut être très
intéressant
mais je voudrais souligner là un point à
avant qu'il ne soit qu'on soit dans le
dur
on va demander aux agriculteurs très
rapidement de délimiter les zones qui
seront considérés comme des et qui
seront considérés comme des éléments
stratégiques au niveau de l'écologie
sauf que ça va rare de conséquences
la première c'est que les surfaces vont
être exclues des aides Pâques
puisqu'elles ne seront plus dans les
périmètres ce qui veut dire que chaque
fois qu'un agriculteur va avoir une haie
va avoir un talus va avoir un espace qui
pourrait rentrer dans la fonction au
niveau de l'agroécologie et bien
effectivement il va s'en trouver
pénalisé
et la conséquence immédiate votre
objectif qu'on pourrait partager qu'on
pourrait rejoindre va citer
effectivement à supprimer les bassins
inciter à supprimer les talus pour une
simple raison au nom de quoi un paysan
irait entretenir une haie un tenir des
éléments
d'accroécologie s'il n'a même plus
d'accompagnement de base à l'intérieur
de ces surfaces donc je souligne ce
poids là parce qu'on va rentrer très
vite dans le dur et vaut mieux en parler
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard et avant
que votre ministère une ministre ne soit
accusé effectivement d'avoir contribué
parce que vous êtes le ministre des
Agriculteurs de France d'avoir contribué
à la disparition de alors que on n'était
pas dans l'objectif là je souligne ce
point là très fort
autre point sur les champs de
l'agriculture le hasard oui le hasard
fait que je suis encore président de la
Chambre d'Agriculture pour quelques
semaines et vice-président de la PCA
sincèrement ce ministre je comprends pas
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
c'est chaque département ce qui fixe son
niveau d'imposition donc on n'est pas
avec un taux uniforme d'imposition dans
les chambres d'agriculture que ce sont
des femmes et des hommes élus qui ont
décidé les niveaux d'imposition et pour
être en situation ça me gêne mais
beaucoup de chance sont dans cette
situation ne pensez pas que lorsqu'on
vous demande monsieur le ministre de
reconsidérer votre date du premier
juillet c'est pour mettre à l'abri de
l'argent qui aurait été
stockés ou au niveau des champs
d'agriculture dans un fond de roulement
trop abondant
vous savez que dans les contes d'une
chambre d'agriculture on peut pas mettre
de ligne pour provision pour
investissement et que c'est
automatiquement dans le fond de
roulement et si je parle de celle que je
connais bien celle des Vosges nous
sommes dans une chambre d'agriculture
type bâtiments ces pairo donc
aujourd'hui on doit refaire des travaux
il y en a pour 4 millions 8 de travaux
nous avons mis de côté année après année
par une bonne gestion de l'argent pour
faire cette investissement encore une
fois je donne cet exemple mais il y a
d'autres exemples la conséquence est de
l'argent de paysans qui viennent du
département de propriétaires qui
viennent du département qui allait être
réinjecté avec des entreprises locales
qu'on a appris de 10% de taux de chômage
monsieur le ministre
me dire qu'on va ponctionner ces moyens
qui ont été constitués par la bonne
gestion
sincèrement j'arrive pas à comprendre et
je pense que les territoires les
départements de France ne peuvent pas
comprendre cela encore une fois c'est
pas pour mettre l'abri c'est pas des
pour les excuses je voudrais aussi dire
une chose
une chose Monsieur le Ministre les
Chambres d'agriculture ce sont des
conseils indépendants qui va aller aider
vous aider dans l'objectif d'atteindre
les 50% l'agroécologie horizon 2025
sinon les techniciens des champs
d'agriculture les chambres d'écriture
elles ne vendent rien
on n'est pas on est là pour apporter un
conseil qui s'occupe aujourd'hui avec la
diminution pour vous dire la pas dire
l'abandon complète complet du soutien
aux agriculteurs en difficulté c'est des
chambres d'agriculture qui font les
études pour aller renégocier avec les
banques pour essayer de sauver les
exploitations qui se trouvent en
situation de grande fragilité je termine
sur le plan modernisation là aussi je
tiens à vous dire ma satisfaction de
voir sa mise en oeuvre j'en suis heureux
je souhaiterais que les régions
considèrent et saisissent l'opportunité
que vous leur donnez de vous accompagner
voir les départements parce que certains
départements y compris pourraient y
contribuer par contre je souhaiterais
savoir si on pourrait aller dans un
guichet unique au niveau l'instruction
des dossiers pour simplifier
effectivement la mécanique et surtout
évitons les distorsions de concurrence
qui pourraient exister par rapport au
choix de priorité parce que
l'installation d'un agriculteur c'est
bien mais maintenir un agriculteur en
élevage qui a 40 ans ou 50 ans s'est
préparé sur l'installation et enfin je
voudrais vous entendre sur le fond
stratégique bois parce que là encore si
on veut soutenir et s'occuper des petits
propriétaires forestiers dont s'occupe
notamment les Chambres d'agriculture je
crains que ce qui est proposé
aujourd'hui de déstabilise et ne nous
permettent pas d'atteindre l'objectif de
mobilisation supplémentaire pour la
richesse et l'emploi du secteur
forestier bien merci à désagré billets
alors j'ai en fait deux interventions
monocytos et ensuite Franck qui m'a
demandé à la parole montéger donc
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
vous arrangerez les choses de votre
façon ça ne peut rien que vous êtes
ministre d'ailleurs
comme vous l'expliquez un certain nombre
de choses vous allez vous expliquer le
cas de la Chambre d'Agriculture et
spécifique que vous pouvez pas nous dire
bien entendu que tu avais que les vaches
sont maigres vous êtes obligés de racler
partout et de les prendre l'argent par
là où il est etc etc bon la vérité
monsieur Grigny vient de le dire c'est
que les comptes publics étant ainsi fait
et mal fait d'ailleurs qu'il n'y a pas
de provision pour investissement
possible pas possible et donc c'est sur
le sur le fond de roulement et je n'ai
rien à rajouter à ce qu'il a dit il est
vrai qu'il y a des chambres de
l'agriculture sont pleins d'amiante qui
sont et cetera et cetera il faut les
refaire ou au minimum faire des travaux
et donc en bon gestionnaire et
provisionne parce qu'ils n'allaient pas
emprunter je sais pas si ils ont eu
l'autorisation 100% de l'investissement
et vous le rendez impossible finalement
monsieur le ministre ces travaux enfin
ça a été très bien dit je voudrais
également parler de l'assurance récolte
monsieur le ministre pour vous dire mais
arrêtez arrêtons et trouvons une autre
solution arrêtons de prélever sur le
premier pilier en permanence je pense
que le deuxième pilier il est également
fait pour cela
et il faut revoir il faut revoir de fond
en comble cette assurance récolte
d'autant plus que certains assurés vous
savez que pour avoir l'assurance récolte
il faut quasiment prendre l'assurance
récolte chez qui vous êtes assuré pour
contre la grêle quasiment et il y a des
erreurs qui refusent de vous assurer
elles sont se récolte autrement dit si
vous n'avez pas votre assurance grêle
chez Groupama vous pouvez pas être
rassuré assurance récolte je parle de ce
que je sais bon donc il y a un vrai
problème que vous feriez bien monsieur
le ministre de regarder très près en
rendant obligatoire l'acceptation
d'assurance par l'assureur un tarif
normal bien entendu je voudrais vous
parler puisque personne ne l'a fait
jusqu'ici de la forêt du programme forêt
des communes forestières et Monsieur le
Ministre le budget passe de 317 millions
à 279 millions cette année pour les
forêts
et je fais remarquer qu'en 2012 ce
budget était 349 millions d'euros par
conséquent ça fait une baisse de 70
millions d'euros alors on comprend mieux
dans ces conditions pourquoi au mois de
septembre dernier ou fin août vous aviez
émis la possibilité de doubler ou
multiplié par je ne sais plus combien la
cotisation à l'hectare pour les forêts
et également le pourcentage prélevé sur
le sur le chiffre d'affaires forêt alors
je sais très bien que la Fédération des
communes forestières
est vivement intervenu et vous avez
accepté de surseoir à cette décision
discuter en 2015 pour mettre en place en
2016 quand même monsieur le ministre il
faut quand même bien regarder les choses
parce que ou alors vous cherchez à faire
disparaître l'OMF je ne sais pas
bon parce qu'il y a beaucoup de communes
qui refuseront de faire gérer leur
commune par l'ONF le front gérer dans le
cadre de la loi des lois fondamentale
forestières mais par le privé et non
plus par l'OMF alors si vous voulez
conserver l'OMF et vous venez de le dire
c'est noté c'est enregistré et bien
faites en sorte que les communes
forestières ne soient pas étranglés par
les cotisations obligatoires
merci Bruno Sidot maintenant dernière
intervenant Franck montoger merci merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre merci d'abord pour votre
présentation
de la politique agricole française et la
manière dont vous mettez un évidence les
équilibres et les cohérences qui sont
qui sont la sienne en faisant des
parallèles entre les différentes mesures
et en les reliant les unes aux autres
avec beaucoup de cohérence je voudrais
tirer votre attention sur la question
des nitrates le département du Gers dont
je suis l'élu et concerné puisque la
totalité du territoire va être touché
par cette cette directive et bien
entendu que la France a mis beaucoup
beaucoup trop de temps à la traduire au
plan national puisque le réglementation
a une vingtaine d'années il n'en reste
pas moins que
nous agriculteurs ont quelques
difficultés à comprendre qu'on ne les ai
pratiquement pas associé à l'élaboration
de ces cartes ils en appel à
discernement
à la prise en compte de particularités
locales qui veulent peau qui veulent
pour le GR comme pour d'autres
territoires concernés et parallèlement à
ça il
monte indiqué qu'il y avait des études
scientifiques en cours
visant à reconsidérer cette cette
problématique là et il évidemment ils en
espèrent des des conclusions qui
pourraient justement permettre d'adapter
ses cartes pour pour faire en sorte que
que certains territoires
puissent puisse puisse fonctionner au
plan agricole de manière de manière plus
plus facile voilà donc je voudrais
savoir ce que vous pouvez nous nous en
dire quand à l'interprétation quand
c'est le ministère et peut-être ce qui
pourra en résulter
il nous reste quelques instants je le
ministre pour prolonger cet échange et
vous souhaitez vous interroger sur un
sujet qui est local dans le département
de l'ordre mais nationale par rapport à
l'intérêt que nous portons tous à la
filière équine il y a dans le
département de l'Orne à Arras qui est le
Haras du pain qui est le Versailles du
cheval
nous avions eu
les autres vont pas être contents c'est
le Versailles du cheval je n'ai jamais
entendu c'est la première fois il entend
que cette expression est contestée bon
nous avons accueilli monsieur le
ministre cet été à l'occasion des Jeux
équestres mondiaux c'était absolument
magnifique ou haras du pain alors dans
la loi à venir de l'agriculture il y a
un centre de disposition qui ont été
votés concernant la réorganisation du
Haras du pain la gouvernance etc je
voulais savoir comment se présenter la
mise en place de ces dispositions et
notamment de cette gouvernance monsieur
le ministre vous avez la parole
alors sur la gouvernance on a mis en
place
un système de pilotage état région
département
qui se met en oeuvre alors je ferai le
point directement avec vous mais ça se
passe plutôt bien même très bien je suis
très satisfait de la manière dont on a
travaillé ensemble
et le décret voilà c'est ce qu'on est en
train de décrire en préparation est en
cours donc le travail ça consiste à
appliquer les collectivités dans la
gestion de ce magnifique patrimoine qui
est peut-être
pas mais peut-être quand même le
Versailles du cheval
mais
elle vous donnerait des citations de
personnes
réputées pour le redécuter intellectuel
qui parle toujours du Versailles du
cheval donc voilà objectif se donner des
moyens avec une diversification
stratégique aussi sur les activités du
haras avec les objectifs en termes
touristiques de remettre ces lieux il y
en a il y a pas que le Haras du pain il
y en a d'autres il faut qu'on leur donne
effectivement une activité des
perspectives stratégiques qui n'ont plus
aujourd'hui vous connaissez la situation
mais ce qui se passe sur la RAT du pain
faire pour nous en tout cas pour
d'autres lieux d'autres sites justement
pour assurer une meilleure gestion et
coordination entre l'État et cet
établissement public français du cheval
qui est nécessaire qui est important et
sur lequel il faut qu'on soit vigilant
sur J'ai oublié de répondre à une
question sur le sur France agrimaire en
gros juste pour donner la structure du
financement enfin des des moyens qui
sont ceux de France agrimaire en loi de
finance initiale 2014 on était à 97
millions d'euros dont 87 millions sur la
ligne budgétaire 154 et 10 millions pour
le casse d'art c'est vrai qu'en PLF 2015
on va passer à 93 millions d'euros donc
97 93 25 millions sur la ligne
budgétaire 154 28 millions sur le casse
d'art et 40 millions liés au paysa
c'est-à-dire au fait qu'on va chercher
là à compléter pour que en fait le bilan
de ses capacités de financement de
France à gr immer le soir réduit que de
4 millions d'euros mais qu'en plus
garder la France agrimaire ce que je
souhaite c'est son lieu de débat
stratégique le les conseils spécialisés
et puis les développements d'action en
particulier avec le casse d'art dans le
cadre de l'agroécologie alors après
je bailli sur les relations commerciales
la GMS question qui a été posée les
regroupements qui sont faits aujourd'hui
sur les centrales d'achat se font dans
un cadre juridique qui est qui s'est
alors c'est pas des c'est pas des
regroupements c'est des accords de
coopération ils ont bien pris soin de ne
pas
aller sur un terrain juridique qui
aurait pu être
difficile pour eux ça nous a pas empêché
le ministre de l'Économie l'a dit de
saisir l'autorité de la concurrence
parce que il faut combattre une pression
sur ce sujet je vous précise monsieur
ministre nous aussi oui nous avons pris
une décision que j'ai formalisée par un
courrier au président de la Haute
Autorité j'ai vu ça c'est très juste et
ça corait ça ça ne peut que deux concert
parfait objectif là ensuite dans les
discussions qu'on a eu quand on a fait
la table ronde générale avec tous les
grands distributeurs plus l'ensemble des
professionnels les industries de
l'agroalimentaire
ce qui a été dit en particulier pour le
cas Auchan Système U c'est que Système U
qui revendique via son président serge
Papin une politique plus accommodante en
termes de prix ne pouvait plus s'en
sortir tout seul ou il allait
disparaître donc lui c'était vital de se
rapprocher d'un autre grand distributeur
et que deuxièmement ce qu'il disait et
j'en ai discuté un peu après avec lui
c'est que au contraire le fait que
Auchan systemus deviennent
le troisième ou le quatrième ou le
deuxième opérateur compte tenu de leur
ligne stratégique par rapport
à l'île de huit stratégique économique
qui n'est pas uniquement la baisse des
prix va donner un poids à un opérateur
qui est le numéro 2 ou 3 je crois qui va
peser sur les autres aussi et c'est ce
que me disait serge Papin tenez compte
de ça
ce qu'il faut c'est pas simplement le
regroupement c'est ce regroupement là il
a plutôt tendance à peser par rapport
aux autres dans un sens plutôt
positivement on va regarder tout ça il
faut être extrêmement vigilant parce que
rien n'est acquis je signale que la
semaine dernière je suis allé signé
une charte de des
acheteurs responsables c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a une discussion entre la grande
distribution et les industriels pour
définir des critères
des critères de responsabilité commune
entre les grands distributeurs et les
industriels et éviter ce qu'on connaît
c'est-à-dire cette espèce de guerre des
prix qui fait qu'on peut revenir sur des
négociations les marges arrières les
référencesments tout ça donc il y a une
charte qui est en train de se construire
les premiers qui ont demandé à être
signataires de cette charte c'est
système justement tout de suite et puis
après elle sera donnée c'est comme un
label en fonction des du respect des
critères ce qui est là aussi pour Mor
réaliser les relations commerciales et
éviter ce qu'on connaît donc on avance
quand même dans une démarche de
compromis et de dialogue entre l'agrand
distribution et les industriels pour
arrêter ce qui est quand même
destructeur aujourd'hui surtout dans une
phase de déflation où les prix basses
c'est par définition c'est pas ça qui va
aujourd'hui augmenter le chiffre
d'affaires puisque on est en déplacement
on y est donc les consommateurs c'est
pas la baisse des prix qu'ils attendent
au contraire s'il anticipe d'ailleurs
ils attendent pour acheter
c'est ça le principe de la déflation
donc je l'ai déjà dit j'ai rencontré un
grand leader là de la grande
distribution en disant j'ai bien regardé
vos chiffres le la progression de votre
chiffre d'affaires ne s'est pas faite
globalement sur la baisse des prix elle
s'est faite sur des démarches
commerciales spécifiques en particulier
le commerce de proximité ou là j'ai vu
que vous aviez progressé de 4% donc on
est bien dans une stratégie qui n'est
plus uniquement comme ça a été le cas
avec Leclerc je baisse les prix j'amène
du monde et je crois et c'est ce qu'il a
fait 19% des parts de marché aujourd'hui
Leclerc mais aujourd'hui ce qui
développent leur chiffre d'affaires
c'est parce qu'ils innovent dans les
stratégies commerciales d'organisation
de relation donc il faut qu'ils en
tiennent tout le monde doit prendre
conscience de ça aujourd'hui et ça
commence mais il faut qu'on soit
vigilant donc on a prévu de mettre un
observatoire le suivi est-ce que
l'observatoire des prix va plus être
valable si il restera valable parce que
de toute façon il s'occupe pas de savoir
qui achète il fait un point sur les prix
à la production les prix à
transformation et les prix à la
distribution et comment se répartit
cette fameuse valeur ajoutée donc il est
toujours très utile il envoie quand même
des messages qui sont importants donc là
dessus on est tous d'accord et c'est
vrai que j'avais oublié de dire que
j'avais oublié le fait que vous avez
vous aussi saisi
l'Autorité de la concurrence c'est très
bien l'avoir fait ça correspond tout à
fait à l'état d'esprit dans lequel on
est et vous voyez bien qu'on a quand
même progressé pour forcer les gens à
discuter les obliger à prendre des
engagements éviter que tout le monde se
regarde et se renvoie la responsabilité
puis à la fin c'est où c'est vers le
ministre et là c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué donc là dessus moi ma
stratégie c'est celle là plus la loi
Hamon qui arrive décret publié respect
de la loi maximum avec la dgcf qui s'est
engagée à faire les contrôles
nécessaires sur l'application de cette
loi alors ensuite je vais répondre
toujours à Monsieur Bailly mais en même
temps je vais passer au nitrate
et là sur les nitrates bon
où est-ce qu'on a été rattrapé
scientifié c'est pour ça qu'il y a un
problème scientifique on a été rattrapé
sur la question de l'eutrophisation
c'est à dire le fait que lorsque vous
avez trop de nourriture dans l'eau elle
développe des végétaux qui bouffent
l'oxygène de l'eau et qui fait que la
biodiversité
se trouve complètement modifié au début
les premières cartes qu'on a donné
c'était sur l'autre fixation maritime
c'était dans les estuaires c'est là où
les grands bassins versants finissent
c'est-à-dire dans la mer et là il y
avait des risques de trophées
j'évoque les algues vertes mais c'était
pas les agréable parce que là pour le
coup la Bretagne est en zone misérable
depuis le départ donc c'est pas le sujet
c'est sur les autres il y avait ça donc
on a fait des premières cartes et où on
faisait on prenait la règle des 15 mg
de d'azote
pour considérer que c'était le seuil à
partir duquel il pouvait y avoir un
risque d'autorisation et à partir de là
on remontait du bassin de l'histoire
maritime jusque dans les zones
continentales et on avait fait des
premières cartes pour voir là où ils
pouvaient y avoir des risques de
pollution qui amené des nutriments
favorisant l’autrophisation mais on
s'est fait retoquer là-dessus
et ils nous ont dit c'est pas que notre
utilisation maritime mais vous devez
prendre aussi ce qui est alors là
l'autorisation continentale
c'est à dire des nappes
qui sont dans les bassins
hydrographiques et c'est ce qui nous
oblige à refaire les cartes et là à
augmenter la surface des eaux durables
et en particulier à tomber sur des zones
extensives du type du Massa du bassin
allaitant du Massif central qui pour les
agriculteurs totalement
incompréhensibles
d'accord alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait à
partir de là parce que ça c'est constat
on a été obligé de répondre à la cour de
justice et à la Commission pour éviter
d'être sanctionné donc maintenant ça
c'est passé donc maintenant il faut
qu'on travaille sur quoi 1 sur cette
question scientifique de notre
utilisation
parce que la directive c'est le risque
de trophée
mais est-ce que les cases d'azote
si vous êtes en eau continental si vous
êtes en nombre maritime si vous avez de
la température vous en avez pas si vous
avez du flux ou pas est-ce que vous êtes
à tout ça ça rentre en ligne de compte
vous le savez bon donc là on commence à
revoir des critères au niveau
scientifique et on a engagé j'ai demandé
à l'INRA Lyr sta de travailler là-dessus
d'accord et donc on va rebalayer toute
les publications qu'il y a et on va
essayer de travailler pour apporter des
bases scientifiques à une contestation
si on doit le faire parce que si on n'a
pas de base scientifique pour le faire
la Commission va nous dire vous faites
ça pour ces dilatoires ça marche pas
donc là on travaille déjà là dessus ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième c'est
on est en train
aussi de regarder et je pense qu'on va y
arriver à savoir si au lieu de prendre
les
territoires de manière administrative
la commune tout entière on pourrait pas
puisque maintenant avec les satellites
et avec la réussite en plus de Rosetta
maintenant on a mais avec les satellites
la mesure du bassin hydrographique parce
que aujourd'hui on pouvait pas prendre
autre chose que les normes
administratives puisqu'il n'y avait rien
d'autre sur lequel on pouvait s'appuyer
de reconnu pour savoir si dans une zone
vulnérable jusqu'où elle va l'enjeu je
vous le dis c'est de ramener tout au
bassin hydrographique et là ça va faire
voilà je peux vous le dire donc on
commence à travailler mais là encore
il faut qu'on crée la base de données et
on ira à la commission d'ici la fin
d'année avec ça en tête je vous le dis à
vous parce que sera des conséquences
importantes ça va réduire les zones
vulnérables qu'on avait présenté mais
qu'on avait présenté parce qu'on n'avait
pas d'autres critères on a pas de base
là on commence à la on commence à
avancer sérieusement bon donc vous voyez
voilà ça c'est la première deuxièmement
sur les plans d'action c'est une fois
qu'on est dans une zone vulnérable c'est
vrai que
la conséquence est de réduire les durées
d'épandage
donc si vous réduisez des durées
dépendrages et que vous avez toujours
les mêmes effluents mais vous êtes
obligés de stocker et c'est tout le
débat sur le stockage c'est ce qui fait
que les agriculteurs se sont visées en
disant et en plus on va demander
d'investir entre 10 20 et 30000 euros
pour stocker alors comment on fait à
partir de là
d'abord on va regarder si des effluents
d'élevage et on appelle ça les fumiers
païeux ne peuvent pas être stockés en
plein champ parce qu'un fumier païeux
c'est pas quelque chose qui
comporte un risque si il est stocké
enfin il comporte un risque de de fuite
mais pas énorme et dans l'arrêt de la
Cour de justice je pense qu'on va
pouvoir obtenir le stockage en plein
champ des fumées payants déjà
tout ce qui est fumier païeux pour être
au temple la chambre donc il y a pas les
investissements pour les agriculteurs
c'est très important ça
très important pour est stockage bon ça
c'est prêt deuxième point est-ce qu'on
peut pas aussi renégocier rediscuter sur
la question des pentes parce
qu'aujourd'hui tout a été exclu à partir
du moment où vous êtes dans une pente de
plus de 15 % vous pouvez plus épandre
quelques autres que ce soit dans l'arrêt
de la Cour de justice il semblerait
quand même qu'ils intègrent l'idée que
si en bas de la pente il y a un ruisseau
c'est vrai que c'est embêtant mais s'il
y a pas de ruisseau donc on va utiliser
ça pour dire les pentes là où il y a pas
de
ben voilà
de la parcelle oui si tu as une pente
avec un ruisseau en bas ben là voilà
mais si tu en as pas c'est la parcelle
s'il y a pas de passe s'il y a si c'est
la partie si elle est pas traversée à ce
moment-là on va discuter avec la
commission sur ce sujet oui la pente
quel est le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui tu ne peux plus et pendre
sur des pentes qui sont supérieures
c'est ça on avait fait remonter 15 15%
d'accord dès que tu es au dessus de 15%,
tu peux plus répondre quel que soit la
parcelle voilà tu es au dessus tu veux
plus
donc on avait réussi à remonter jusqu'à
15% déjà donc on a éliminé une partie de
ce qui était des pentes mais maintenant
on va regarder si même au-delà de 15% si
t'as pas de ruisseau en bas
de considérer qu'on peut épandre donc
c'est de la surface supplémentaire pour
répondre donc du stockage en moi
toujours le même raisonnement je résonne
toujours troisième axe pour moi il est
très important c'est là où se développe
de la méthanisation il faut qu'on puisse
faire du stockage collectif
c'est à dire de dire aux agriculteurs
avec des Cubas organisés au lieu
d'investir tous les uns et les autres
pour avoir un peu plus de de stockage
potentiel avec du béton que chacun est
obligé d'investir ça serait beaucoup
mieux en termes de dépenses publiques
que le concentrer sur un lieu où on peut
stocker puisqu'il y a de la
méthanisation derrière et là tout ce qui
va là n'est pas non plus compter comme
effluent à stocker dans l'exploitation
troisième possibilité ouverte pour
limiter l'investissement quatrième piste
c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'autoconstruction fixer des règles qui
permettent aux agriculteurs de régler
les petits problèmes de stockage plutôt
que d'être obligé de investir refaire et
tout ça donc on va mettre en place aussi
ça donc vous voyez qu'au bout du compte
si je rajoute la redéfinition sur les
bassins et hydrographique si je vais
jusqu'au bout et qu'on obtient de la
part de la Commission sur les fumiers
païeux sur la question des pentes et sur
le stockage collectif on a un dispositif
qui va limiter
les investissements nécessaires à au
minimum et là il faudra qu'on aide et
c'est pour ça qu'on a prévu aussi de
mobiliser les agences de l'autre tout ça
mais venir en appui aux éleveurs donc on
est vraiment dans une stratégie qui tout
en respectant l'engagement que l'on doit
et c'est pas moi la directive nitrate
c'est pas moi qui ai négocié que l'on
doit respecter vis-à-vis de l'Europe et
bien on va tout faire pour diminuer les
risques liés à des investissements dans
les zones vulnérables pour les
agriculteurs et surtout pour les
éleveurs parce que c'est surtout pour
les éleveurs que ça quoi voilà la
stratégie donc tout ça on est en train
de négocier avec le visage environnement
et je le dis sur tous les points que je
vais d'évoquer ça avance très bien et
après on va se retourner vers la
Commission et puis après on va discuter
aussi avec la Commission du de la durée
de la mise en oeuvre de tout ça mais
vous voyez je vous ai dit tout ce que
nous allons faire ça a été dit
à certains responsables professionnels
mais détaillé comme ça je l'ai dit à
l'Assemblée devant le groupe élevage et
je viens de dire cet après-midi devant
le groupe au Sénat voilà et donc je vous
ferai le détail si vous voulez mais vous
vous rappelez bien la question
scientifique la question de la
délimitation hydrographique et les trois
mises en place de plan d'action avec 4
points le premier les fumiers païeux le
deuxième les pentes le troisième le met
de la méthanisation quatrième
l'autoconstruction d'accord voilà les
lacs stratégiques qu'on va suivre bon
alors sur voilà ça c'est important bon
le loup j'y reviens pas c'est vrai que
si on pouvait
voilà et ça on l'a déjà fait pas mal il
faut qu'on continue je vous le dis au
passage j'ai engagement que j'avais pris
au Sénat de prendre des contacts avec
les autres pays européens sur la
Directive Habitat
contact plutôt positif avec l'Espagne
qui a aussi un problème aujourd'hui de
de d'extension de alors que jusqu'ici
ils avaient pas trop de problèmes
aujourd'hui ils sont prêts à discuter
avec nous d'une discussion sur la
Directive Habitat qui permettrait
ensuite d'avoir des actions qui se
repars remises en cause en particulier
par les tribunaux administratifs quand
tu es préfets prennent des décisions de
tirs bon donc j'ai commencé les Italiens
là j'arrive j'ai du mal et puis en plus
son président italienne j'ai pas mais
l'Espagne est prête à avoir une démarche
avec nous c'est important je l'avais dit
pendant les débats je l'ai fait j'ai
commencé à travailler là-dessus
sur
l'aide sur les 21 pays débat qui a aussi
avec le mystères des finances j'ai vu
Michel Sapin je suis parti là-dessus
mais faut être vigilant il faut qu'à
l'échelle européenne les aides les aides
le financement des soutiens sur
l'embargo russe ça soit d'abord une
partie des sanctions qui ont été payées
par d'autres agriculteurs pas la France
que ça n'a pas dépassé notre quota mais
quand même on va pas payer trois fois
trois fois parce qu'on règle pas
l'embargo une fois après parce que on va
vider le fond de crise et puis une
troisième parce que toutes les sanctions
ont été payées elles sont remises dans
le budget je l'ai dit encore Michel
Sapin il y a 5 milliards je vous le dis
quand même de sanctions qui sont payés
là et sur les 5 milliards nous c'est que
400 millions
c'est ce que je leur ai dit vous avez
quand même de la marge pour parce que il
y a un problème budgétaire aussi au
niveau européen vous avez vu les débats
je vous fais pas de dessin mais mais
quand même ça je souhaite et là dessus
il faut qu'on soit soutenu bien sûr si
vous et toutes les relations ici qu'il y
a entre la Commission le Sénat est le
Parlement européen prenez la démarche
tout de suite parce que j'ai vu Jean
Arthur ils sont quand même eux plutôt
sur cette ligne là donc il faut qu'on
soit coordonné au niveau des parlements
donc faut aller reprendre les contacts
là puisque je sais qu'il y a des vous
avez une commission Europe
monsieur le Président dans le droit fil
direction le Parlement européen et vous
soutenez la position de la France quoi
je le dis ça ça peut nous aider et il
faut qu'on s'aide mutuellement moi j'ai
pas de là-dessus il faut le faire sur
les retraites agricoles alors on avance
on avance sur les retraites agricoles en
gros et on a avancé oui en 2014 la loi a
été votée les décrets sont parus en juin
2014 julie a cette petite note bien
faite de
budgétaire première mesure la RCO la
retraite complémentaire obligatoire 30
euros par mois en moyenne 400000
bénéficiaires surtout bien sûr des
femmes puisque c'était pour elle que
cette retraite complémentaire était fait
75% du SMIC alors on en est où monter en
puissance et se marquer mais c'était
l'objectif qui était fixé donc en 2015
on sera à 73 % en 2016 à 74 en 2017 à 75
donc aujourd'hui pour l'année prochaine
on atteindra 73% du SMIC pour les
retraites agricoles voilà c'est précis
de pas faire mieux là le forfait oui on
a une discussion sur le forfait ça c'est
vrai sur la viticulture en particulier
sur le croustillant sujet donc moi là
dessus on a modifié les règles
ce qui fait d'ailleurs que sortant du
forfait pour certains pourront
bénéficier ensuite du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité
mais le forfait est un problème en
particulier pour ceux qui depuis
plusieurs années avaient été dans le
forfait
et on a mis de côté
à fond pour gérer cette transition parce
que je sais que ça peut avoir des
conséquences de transfert entre ceux qui
vont sortir du forfait ceux qui vont y
entrer et les 7 millions d'euros
d'économies qui sont faites sur le
fonctionnement de ce système forfaitaire
qui existait aujourd'hui catastrophe en
terme de comment dirais-je oui c'est 150
TP c'est surtout 13% pour le coup de
gestion 13%. donc
l'économie qu'on fait là-dessus donc là
simplification tient si on discute entre
nous ça sera pour la suite tout ça c'est
l'État qui allège ses procédures mais
j'ai gardé et Bercy à accepter c'est
très important pour moi c'est que les
économies qu'on fait sur la gestion que
Bercy fait sur la gestion je les garde
pour gérer la transition parce qu'il y
aura peut-être des effets à corriger à
lisser parce que ceux qui sortent d'un
seul coup du forfait et qui se mettent à
payer il faut qu'on soit capable de le
faire ça concerne en particulier je le
dis l'ensemble
de sur la viticulture et je serai très
attentif à ça très attentif pour éviter
les effets les effets qui pouvaient être
néfastes mais la profession agricole a
accepté de sortir le système ça fait
simplifier les mesures de recouvrement
ça fait 7 ou 8 millions d'économies bon
voilà pour Bercy qui redéplo ailleurs
franchement je pense que là mais il faut
être toujours être attentif sur ces
sujets fiscaux il faut éviter les effets
de transfert donc ça sera fait je vous
promets et on a mis de côté les
économies pour justement traiter la
transition
j'en ai parlé et si eux mais aujourd'hui
les 30% de verdissement c'est une partie
des aides des pb sont liées au
verdissement ou au Père 30% ou on les
garde sont liés au respect de ces
facteurs de verdissement prairie
permanentes surface d'intérêt écologique
dans lequel d'ailleurs on a repris la
réglementation européenne et uniquement
la réglementation européenne c'est
reproduction de légumineuses tout ce qui
peut être intégré alors sur la question
des haies si les existent aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire qu'elles sont il y a des
TPU bon les transferts sont les DPD je
vois pas comment on aurait un effet de
substitution mais je vais vérifier ça
sur la question parce que c'est souvent
venu ça
leur dire le débat elles vont être
identifiées et elles vont être sortis de
la parcelle par l'homme j'ai une
parcelle de cinq hectares 30 j'ai une
haie qui fait 30 Arte
aujourd'hui tant qu'elle n'est pas un
pourcentage il y a un pourcentage
autorisé et heureusement parce que sinon
il y aura bientôt il y aura longtemps
c'est comme pour les animaux lorsque
vous avez quelques armes dès lors que
les animaux peuvent rentrer dans dans
dans la partie boisée si ça se passe ça
dépasse pas une surface un coefficient
c'est aussi éligible
je vais regarder ça parce qu'en fait ce
que je sais c'est que s'il y a pas le
verdissement sur les critères que
j'évoquais diversification de la
production tout le débat tiens qu'on a
eu sur le maïs et sur la couverture
hivernale du maïs on l'a réglé on va
intégrer dans la diversification les
couvertures hivernales du maïs alors le
la GPB la GPM plutôt voulait uniquement
le mulch ça c'était pas possible mais la
couverture idéale va être intégrée très
importante donc là dessus ils vont
pouvoir sur la diversification intégrée
cette diversification pour le
verdissement mais c'est sur les cieux
sur les haies ça fait un moment qu'on me
parle de ça je vais regarder ça et je
vous répondrai précisément bon sur
les coopératives sur le cice elles vont
bénéficier de la suppression anticipée
de la C3S c'est à dire qu'on y a pensé
quand même aux coopératives et en même
temps comme être payé pas d'impôts sur
les sociétés c'est difficile de les
faire bénéficier du crédit d'impôt mais
il y a ça à faire fond stratégique sur
le bois
oui oui mais c'est pour ça qu'on a on a
choisi de c'est pour ça qu'on a choisi
de de d'accélérer la C3S les
coopératives vont bénéficier tout de
suite et en gros le cice pour les cops
parce que comme elles ont beaucoup
physialisés quand même dire que toutes
les filiales des coq elle touche le cri
d'impôt compétitivité donc ce qui
restait en terme de crédit d'impôts
l'estimation qu'on avait fait sur les
cops c'était 100 millions
l'anticipation de ces trois SD l'année
prochaine ça fera ça fera oui 50
millions d'euros donc la moitié de ce
qui aurait été le potentiel du crédit
d'impôt sera versé au travers de la
suppression de ces trois espèces pour
les coopératives en anticipation donc on
a quand même traité le sujet
et les coopératives
Club de France était contente alors sur
le fond stratégique et le bois ONF
cofore vous l'avez dit il y avait
un sujet moi je suis attaché au fond
forestier et à la gestion de la forêt
public avec l'ENF parce que je sais que
il y a des forêts publiques qui sont
productives et qui aujourd'hui tant
mieux valorise le bois et donc on des
ressources et puis il y en a d'autres
aujourd'hui qui valorisent rien du tout
et qu'on a surface forestière qui coûte
et c'est très difficile à gérer si on
n'a pas nos régimes forestier on gère
pas ça donc il faut garder ce régime ça
veut dire gardez l'ONF il faut que vous
sachiez quand même que pour ce qui est
de l'ENF en dehors du COP du contrat
d'objectif qui avait été signé moi j'ai
rajouté depuis que je suis arrivé en
2012 près de 100 millions d'euros pour
l'ONF
donc on leur a demandé sur les 100
millions d'euros qu'on avait rajouté sur
le sur l'ONF en terme de soutien l'an
dernier on avait voté vous aviez voté +
30 millions d'euros de cette année c'est
comme pour les c'est comme pour les
chambres c'est à dire ce qu'on vous a
augmenté la subvention de près de son
lion on vous demande de faire l'effort
de 20 millions d'euros qu'on aurait
demandé sinon en augmentant les taxes
sur le centime forestier pour les
communes forestières et qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire maintenant on va essayer de
renégocier l'ensemble du dispositif mais
je le dis moi je suis attaché et je
reste attaché au régime forestier voilà
pour cette audition de Stéphane Le Foll
le ministre de l'Agriculture qui a été
auditionné par les sénateurs de la
commission des affaires économiques du
Sénat rappelons que l'agriculture c'est
un sujet très important ici au Sénat
puisque de nombreux sénateurs
représentent les territoires ruraux
d'autant plus important que les
agriculteurs ont récemment montré leur
exaspération à travers des
manifestations la semaine dernière